[Music]
foreign
happy Friday friends out there in the
cyberweb
friends at home
February 10th boy boy boy joined today
by the lovely and sweet and very funny
uh idubbbz and Anissa
really Ian right uh you can call me Ann
you can call me idubbbz it's easier
because you have
a second Ian here so idubbbz works
better okay I don't think there'll be
any confusion but I mean he's back there
he doesn't I heard the name Ian just a
minute ago and I was about to respond to
it
how you guys been nice to see you all
again
good to see you guys good night on the
verge of another Creator Clash yes yeah
we're training very hard my body Fat's
going down and it's very cold in this
studio and I'm shivering really yes we
can we can adjust that for you that's
all right I'll live you've lost 20
pounds really yeah so he fought at 188
and he's 168 right now what's Alex weigh
uh about the same your opponent Alex
wassabi's a giant [__] you're gonna
[__] kill him some people call him
Wasabi I don't want to call him that
because I think that's uh demeaning uh
to women because right it is a little
bit I don't like that term uh so we're
calling him Alexander horseradish which
we think is a much more appropriate name
and you move towards like a little bit
what what is the significant of the
insult of a horserad a Wasabi I get it I
get it it's kind of the widified version
of Wasabi yeah it's really not good yeah
you're being really respect thankful to
him actually I talked a bit about it on
my members live but this is your
opponent and this guy went with fousey
to get the billion dollar smile you know
about that oh my favorite videos ever
that was him yeah the million dollar
smile he got crazy fake veneers from
this con man and I remember watching
yeah
he does it for free for influencers and
then hey Gabe what's up buddy
[Applause]
[Music]
oh you're in like Target some [__]
I'm going some Valentine's Day shopping
for my favorite lucky girl you got the
Versace
yeah her name is Leia oh wait there is a
lucky girl really
Leia wait hold on so last time we spoke
with you you mentioned the possibility
of cuddling over the weekend was that
something that happened
[Music]
but did you hang out with her
did you guys was there chemistry was
there Sparks
something like that
we found out about I I wanna these are
my friends gay but Ian and Anissa hi
Gabe hey Gabe this is white claw game
yeah
yeah Gabe told us last week we had a
revelation that he's actually virgin
and uh he was going on some kind of date
or was it a date or who's the how did
you guys hang out
just like hang out like do some like
talk and stuff that's about it oh that's
nice talking is good yeah
[__] yeah dude well the Valentine's Day
present is a good idea
what are you thinking oh yeah
I'm thinking maybe a purse oh [__]
that's expensive though nice can I
suggest a purse is maybe laying it thick
after one week of dating do you guys
know what I mean like maybe coming on
too strong especially like the Versace
bracelet oh a bracelet oh I like it but
nothing like super expensive right maybe
like an anime t-shirt or some hot topics
maybe something special or something
I can help you shop you have any ideas I
mean like we could we could give you our
feedback
maybe perfume
perfume's almost a backhanded gift it's
like you stink wear this yeah
yeah hey why didn't you go to amaranth's
Party dude that was like you would have
loved it there
[Music]
um party
yeah he's never heard of it guys
amaranth's party there was a big party
in Hollywood that ever all the crew went
to they said that everyone was asking
where's White Cloud Gabe now Gabe says
angry and I'm looking at you he says
he's never heard of her so what do we so
what does that mean
um I don't know to talk to you uh Nick
his nephew he was the middleman okay but
thanks for looking at me
I got nothing to do with this party you
guys thought this was gonna vindicate
you now I just feel even worse for Gabe
he never got the invite no one
wow I said we got to go after his nephew
now
all right find a good gift for your lady
there for your lady friend
maybe maybe for Valentine's Day just
like take her out for dinner maybe no
gift it's only been one week I I think
dinner yeah
maybe it's a better idea yeah take her
to The Melting Pot The Melting Pot of
fondue oh yeah I've never been there
like you just melt it in a pot yeah they
like bring out like it's like a coarse
meal so there's like appetizer meal and
then dessert desserts oh my pot yeah
really they bring out different pots
there's like oils buns made out of a pot
I mean it sounds a little [__] so
good no it's hey boy it's your personal
a trough as long as everyone's eating
out of the same trough it's like a hot
pot for white people
okay
I eat hot or wait hot pot's that Korean
thing yeah
all right Gabe I gotta go be good okay
[__] on my
dick [__]
who's the [__] is Uncle gay
okay
smear [__] under my pupa and put your
neck down [__]
oh how about this moisturize
moisturize my hair with your diarrhea
baby
did you come up with that yeah it's what
we do every Friday
the limits of our obscenities
what shirts my hair with my comb oh
good
oh okay you went there Gabe you dirty
boy all right well the connection's so
bad I'm gonna let you go but we'll talk
to you next week okay let's get to the
bottom of this amaranth party because
this could be a whole new
thread to pull on yeah ask Gabe about
amaranth let's see if he knows Nick I
mean Nick Nick what'd I say okay
Gabe take care okay we love you
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
oh this is this is exciting actually
because
I'd really like for him to get a little
[Music]
um
I mean second day and date is that's a
big deal oh yeah on Valentine's Day on
Valentine's yeah
here is a picture of your opponent Alex
wasabi
yeah it's the horseradish comes from
like he's from Kentucky and he's I don't
think he's he's from Kentucky he's like
an idiot
um and I don't think he's Japanese so I
don't know where the Wasabi even comes
from so horseradish is just it's more
applicable to him those are nice looking
teeth you can't dog those teeth I think
he must have either redone them or
something because they're okay they
don't look that bad although they are
like very obviously veneers find me a a
b can you vet the billion dollar smile
Vlog of his and then show us still of
his and fousey's teeth because they came
out of there looking like right [__]
couple of horses
I think some people it depends on your
face I think some people have a face for
fake teeth and I think like other people
don't I think like
um I think Boogie got fake teeth a while
ago yeah and I just don't think that his
face really like fit the fake teeth I
think he just didn't get a good a good
job probably because it really
eventually sometimes they go too white
they go too big yeah you kind of You
Gotta Have a good doctor you know yeah
eating
he's ready yeah it's like oh very comfy
very very cute yeah so um well okay here
have you ever considered getting veneers
or any teeth type thing no because
the thing is I
I'm afraid I don't know I guess I just
don't care that much at this point in my
life you know there was there was a
point but this is before right don't
people do it out of necessity like I
don't understand no it's for Beauty look
at his feet his teeth such nice teeth
Perfect Smile yeah what's the problem
and Lucy too also had beautiful teeth
yeah so yeah the story is they went down
to Colombia there's this doctor he's
such a [__] goon apparently he has
all these controversies I didn't know
that about it like essay stuff and
straight up conning people not getting
back to people it's awesome Bros so here
he is
putting on the veneers whoa whoa smile
wait he puts it on top it's a veneer
just covers their teeth and then that
face permanent yeah they shave down your
your actual teeth no no no no no no
that's different he doesn't oh he
doesn't yeah
essentially just gets glued on yeah like
a fake nail or something yeah and then
maybe like shave down to the appropriate
so he doesn't shave it
do you oh you mean yeah look at booty
this man looks like he has dentures
oh man and his smile was beautiful
before
there's a dentist on Tick Tock that
Mourns young people's teeth getting
shaved down like they get shaved down
you see them like turn into little Nubs
and then they put that's insane and he's
like this is so sad why do they do that
it's just like it it looks more real so
like when they just like it they look
like little baby shark teeth when they
like shave the teeth down and then they
yeah
I can't but it's like all psycho those
are your teeth man
um so anyway uh so that's your opponent
you're gonna crush him has he ever
fought before oh yeah he's won it now
and I'm owing one so he's putting a
better record veggie ksi's little veggie
not impressed deji almost beat Floyd
Mayweather yeah
uh it's pretty good there when they were
fighting deji and wasabi a guy from the
crowd ran into the ring during the fight
yeah it's kind of terrifying he's in the
UK they're a Rowdy Bunch over why did
they do that they're psychos they were
thinking it's weird okay well all the
British just weird people generally yeah
yeah isn't it boy mate you get a little
pint of beer and I'm so bad
every time we watch the podcast and you
start out with an accent I'm like Ethan
don't I don't hold it bad that's the
other one I feel like I have my next
Tucker my next Tucker but I feel like
there I could have so much fun with the
English one I gotta I wish I could I
work with two British people at Teddy
fresh and just like anything they'll say
sounds like 10 times better because of
that
[Music]
if you focus on the vowels you can do
accents a lot easier so you just like
learn how vowels are pronounced for
different accents it gets like way
easier
do you know how to I'm not gonna do it
yeah we're very opposed to we're
watching Impressions and accents below
deck and there's this one
chips too every time she says she's
Australian but every time she says
Charter Charter yeah I wish I could do
it I love the Australian accent they
just say it's weird they go ER is just a
straight up a yeah like how'd that
happen but ain't none of my business
it's the last time you guys uh you guys
God damn it stop sending me this stuff
you guys this is what they do their
teeth before they put in like the fakies
no that is no scary no no no no I can't
even look at the bad Photoshop it looks
like a little baby shark don't do that
unless you have a problem with your
teeth yeah I look like Aiden Ross a
little bit it did look like
did you not find the after AB of Wasabi
we need to humiliate him before it's a
part two I gotta find it okay okay yeah
it's a part two yeah he click baited it
he's like you guys gotta watch part two
to see my teeth nobody cares dude
by the way um I'm gonna take this off
because now I'm hot
so let me just quickly say Ian are you
trying to start beef with this guy or is
it you can gonna make your fire worse uh
I think there's a sweet spot I think
this level is fine if we didn't go
further with it I'd be happy with that
well it's further what would even be
further be I'm not giving out his
address or anything oh yeah just like
talking about it for another like 20
minutes saying how [__] ugly he is
and how he always sucks and how he's
gonna you know he is handsome though he
has a very nice smile yeah he's
beautiful he oh yeah yeah he's got a gun
well we we went to uh crank gameplay's
house for uh watch party we were
watching like ksi's fight
um and we didn't know that Wasabi was
invited so we're sitting there and Alex
comes in the door and this was recently
yeah so you had to come face to face
with your opponent face to face they sat
and talked did you have to hold you back
no we're very respectful yeah I know I
know you you love respectful fights yeah
me
I like to play dirty you know what I'm
saying
are you closer to fighting oh no turn
that off
turn that off Alex that I will say that
I actually think is your funniest that
is your funniest is the really bad
Italian
Alex Wassabi if that is your real name
actually your teeth look quite nice I
can't lie about it fousey got shafted
and your teeth look beautiful
but my friend Ian here he's gonna have
to
make a mess of that beautiful teeth yes
I do like the flag
your homie's teeth look [__] up
compared to yours why'd you do that to
them
all right whatever nice guy
by the way I'm gonna take this off
because eat little ass Ian's making me
hot as [__] so I'm just gonna say I'm
the hoodie I'm wearing from the new drop
this one here watercolor floral hoodie
you know what it is and there's all
kinds of other stuff here I feel like
you wanna
go up here oh sure I don't know
I just show more on my Instagram if you
guys want to check that out but
um yeah if you scroll down a little bit
Ethan on the homepage
this the vibe for this one was like
black with lots of Pops of color I love
it and I'm just I'm super happy with
every single piece they all came out so
good so the bobby pin is lit yeah I love
the bobby pin thank you
thank you thank you thank you yeah the
cardigan
well there it is pettyfresh.com thank
you thank you peace and love all right
so let's move on from Alex Wasabi the
poor unfortunately soon to be pulverized
you are going to crush him though
because you look real good against Dr
Mike and I feel like you've probably
been training hard since then oh yeah
I've been going crazy I'm not making
videos I'm just training
and second year it's like years last
time you started from nothing right
exercising yeah you probably feel it
right like yeah base is all there yeah
exactly I don't have to like spend nine
months like just learning basically yeah
you look good man the last fight so I'm
I'm scared for him how tall is he uh
like five eleven maybe six oh so you're
a few inches taller maybe no no you're
definitely taller okay yeah after seeing
you guys definitely taller definitely
taller by like an instrument is this
still your last fight
uh maybe we'll see how old it sort of
depends 32. your oldest [__] yeah like
me I thought you were younger I like
having someone in their 30s yeah good at
school
um Alex I think is also 32 around this
okay same age he does have a young face
um
so yeah one of us is coming advertising
or going into retiring one of these
going into the grave bro
yeah but we're all excited here A B
sweet a B's fighting again yes and
unfortunately
he's fighting dad this psycho freak
who's like a freak athlete who has like
freakish dancing skills whose last fight
lasted seven seconds although Matt
Watson famously was not did not put up
much of a fight or even his hands he did
not even put up his hands yeah we were
worried about Matt uh probably a month
before the fight happened we had some
feelings so we actually hunted Matt down
he was at uh the optic party house and
uh Ian strapped up you know got his
headgear on and he was like we're
sparring right now I need to see this oh
God and uh so yeah it wasn't good I mean
nothing really changed from that moment
till fight night yeah Ian was trying to
teach him to drape and kept going like
because Ian would punch him and he would
do this right which you saw in Fight
Night and Ian was like you need to tie
me rape because it's you get tired when
you have uh someone like putting their
weight on you and I I don't think Dad
would have known what to do do but like
it just wasn't in Matt Matt's like
response was to kind of just yeah that
fight was awesome though and by the way
I'm sure you guys must have loved the
Joe Rogan faux pas
thing that must have been so like
gratifying yeah absolutely yeah it made
us want to like like uh orchestrate
things so that like there's more moments
why do they lie
oh why does it lie
oh I love that line yeah I wonder how
you guys can try to trick Joe again
literally I end up just making our
YouTube video and titling it that's the
title you just have to make the title
anything and he also didn't listen to it
with volume on because it was like
commentated like it it was weird I just
love the idea of Joe Rogan sitting it's
late at night he's sitting there crying
poor kid and it's bad
reliving his
life yeah we've watched this a few times
but it it is so good did you make this
edit yeah okay so wait you you made this
and then you sent it to him for the to
post yeah for the clown wow now you are
what a [__] guy you are man
well I mean not really [__] put it
all out there on the line at least he
gets he needs he needs some I like that
he tagged Joey Rogan though like how
there's Toby Turner right there
what the hell
yeah well this guy really turned out to
be a [__] weirdo he hangs out with
Kyle Rittenhouse I know the Nerf gun
post was so crazy he's like Maga now
it's like the biggest twist oh Matt
Watson ratioed him that was awesome yeah
that is sick they heavily ratio this
dude
oh um let's I mean I saw a video today
of a boxing match between a father and a
son
it made me so sad
crying he's so sad because it's just
young daughters he's like Daddy not now
not now sweetie tattoo on his chest
like come on and the father beats the
[__] it doesn't even look like similar
at all
different in age no that's your son like
and we're watching you beat your son up
Dad of being on testosterone which is
very weird it makes me so sad his belly
looks natural he's he's an athlete no no
yeah yeah he's not he's all Natty oh
yeah yeah weird
[Music]
from now on after that it might [__] up
his pituitary gland did you ever worry
about damaging your pituitary gland yeah
uh I mean I suppose I definitely defend
against my pituitary glands the center
of your Dome you have to get rattled
like pretty [__] hard right it's not
like people can Target it yeah is that a
thing why is he talking yeah it is a
thing I think it's like I don't know
it's kind of signaling like I don't know
it just makes him sound like he's
thought about it yeah well like yeah
yeah there's um like a lot of uh War
veterans for example they'll come back
from war and a lot of them have
depression and for a long time they were
diagnosing it as PTSD yeah but they
started doing hormone testing and they
found that like the the shell shock
going off actually did mess with the
pituitary that makes sense when they did
hormone therapy they actually cured
their wow a lot of their issues
pituitary I mean so you could we can
treat the pituitary okay so it's not
that big of a deal well you gotta like
be on hormones right like oh you know
but okay maybe how are you feeling about
your pituitary going up against dad who
brought who damaged Matt's platoon
he should be the pituitary Destroyer I'm
feeling okay I'm not too worried yeah
yeah but we'll see yeah he's going
through pituitary therapy yeah after
each sparring session he goes in it's a
great thing my pituitary I'm kind of
numb to it because it's just everything
I post that's all I get in the comments
is ripped here of pituitary glands oh
really yeah 100
maybe it's just a little maybe he'll be
fine maybe he'll get over it but maybe
you [__] him up that can happen too he
might be depressed from now on after
that it might [__] up the pituitary
gland it happens and you just did that
to yourself so so weird because this
guy's the king of UFC yeah like why like
what are you lecturing about CTE now
it's just so weird oh those guys yeah
yeah like what are you sounding off
about because they're related like I
mean but it really does concern me that
Joe Rogan is the most popular
podcaster in the world Entertainer in
the world probably yeah and a lot of
people get their information from him
and this man genuinely thought I know he
was crying
crying it was so sad but and he never he
didn't talk to anyone about it right
like you think if he was so disturbed by
it he would like have a conversation
with someone and like maybe yeah nothing
would come of it well I was gonna say
well Joe you need to prove uh to your
audience that you care about getting it
right I think they he needs to have Dad
or Matt Watson someone come on the show
who explained their side of the story I
think it's only fair way of doing it
what do they have to say though at the
end of the day no yeah we're not related
dad has to refute the testosterone yeah
yeah because he said oh yeah you know
that guy's on T and it's like you said
that yes he didn't correct that no
I'm being testosterone dude write it out
I missed that he said that yeah well
it's it's not in this video they
continue to talk about it for another
five minutes maybe and they can show The
Real uh like fight but he does have his
testosterone probably though because
like his mustache he's bald as [__] he's
all this [__] and he's got the thickest
mustache I have ever seen him yeah yeah
I've seen that it looks photoshopped
isn't that funny the more testosterone
you have the more bald your ass gets I
didn't know that apparently that's true
really brother
so anyway that's why a lot of it makes
you lose weight I lose hair and angry I
I think there's a relation between the
two of you
also makes your balls tiny well it makes
your balls tiny because when you make
too much testosterone it turns into
estrogen
bait alert yeah because
the the um they're very close in um
chemical makeup okay so the body can
change them the scientist uh Anissa over
here yeah
[Applause]
you're supposed to like touch them up
you're supposed to not even hurt them
like slam them in the body a little bit
like you think you can fight okay good
dudes not too much he's created a whole
family on your son's face on television
it's crazy
how was how old was the kid Jamie you
know what's the problem to me he has no
part of his brain no real skeptical part
of his brain because any sane rationally
thinking person would be like
seems a little far-fetched let me see
yeah Jamie is immediately like this
didn't happen well the video that that
Joe watched is it's got like 20 000
views yeah like and the quality is [__]
there was like nothing about it that
indicated any sort of legitimacy and
like especially when dad's channel the
one on there has like 1.5 million views
or something yeah like why didn't he
just look up father-son boxing match I
feel like it would come up probably I
think or just scroll into the [__]
comments yeah true you know or turn the
volume on but this one yeah but he's
just he's not some like Facebook Uncle
this man is like entertaining me that's
when he gets zooted yeah apparently he
wears a spacesuit or this is what our
coach told yeah our coach is a giant so
in the fighting World everyone's a giant
Joe Rogan fan it's like crazy you can't
escape it so our coach told us right
away that if he's in that suit it's
because he's like he's faded I think it
means that he's about to take DMT and
get into the deprivation tank faded then
hello yeah
as the kids are saying it's like you
know he could be 20. he could be 19. he
looks young he's real skinny and the
father's kind of jacked not too jacked
but you know I love that he really took
note of it but it's the [__] detail
yeah like so much explanation so much
story building yeah
[__] Tolkien over here World building
yeah and he could this gay men aren't
Dramatics and the sun doesn't look like
he has any idea what the [__] he's doing
I don't know what the thing was like
someone sent it to me and they were like
cheering that this old guy knocked his
son out I was like you guys are crazy
it's funny you're like yeah it doesn't
make sense it's crazy right like follow
that thread into it a little bit someone
sent it to him like in an email or
something
do they get in contact I'd like to think
it was like Instagram message requests
right like he went into his message I
got it yeah I gotta know the pipeline
that Joe like to get to Joe Rogan like
it's probably very obscure yeah but they
were probably like look at this silly
thing like laughing yeah totally totally
yeah
um here let's let's enjoy this that you
failed
yeah that's not exactly what was
happening it's not what is it they're
not father son oh why does it lie it
says father knocks out idiot you stupid
idiot like it's their fault like you
idiot you have a little obligation to
your audience don't you think
this guy's a YouTuber and he's a
YouTuber I'm such a sucker and that's
the understatement dude anyway
um before we keep beautiful there's
something I wanted to do with you guys
participate are you allowed to eat pizza
oh yeah sure yeah are you watching your
diet really care yeah it's just yeah I
mean a little bit
what are you eating like chicken breasts
and all that kind of stuff yeah I mean I
could kind of eat whatever I want
whatever fills the uh the stomach and
and I don't know maybe a little protein
heavy
whatever fills the stomach yeah all
right well this fills the stomach cool
this is Dave pork boys enemy of the show
are we friends or enemies
enemies
he was a friend for a minute because he
did one thing I liked I forget your only
friend left online is sitting in front
of you so yeah okay yeah cool we're
gonna try and do something about that
today
so this here is Dave pork boy the pizza
uh
connoisseur he does the one bite
challenge this dude made a pizza for
Walmart
okay and we were joking about the
packaging of it it's one bite
which is not the best way you were
pointing out yeah because it sounds like
it's like one bite and then you're
throwing it down yeah it tastes like
[__] it's just the end
right which is like you can't stop
eating the chips yeah and so their
slogan is you can stop
you will stalker you won't want another
slice I mean maybe even also with the
pizza like have a bite taken out of it
or something yeah it's just not it
doesn't communicate cohesive no he's not
good at branding have you seen his watch
company no brother yeah
um so we're gonna try it and I'm gonna
do this [__] challenge it looks like
[__] and he's such a lying piece of [__]
dude what's the challenge but be honest
with people's videos
what's what's the price
yeah so there was uh seven bucks yeah
there you go
it's better seven Dollar Pizza huh
Shredder so cheap yes I mean yeah it is
cheap but here's where he goes sideways
okay this guy's a [__] liar
and he gives them horrible Pizza reviews
because he's just keeping it real then
this guy has the nerve to step before me
put this dog [__] in his mouth trust me
so this will be an unbiased score that
does not look like the pizza I just saw
no [__] that is oh that looks good yeah
I want to eat that
somebody did a total stranger I'll let
them score it if you don't believe me
I'll let them score it this all shut up
all the critics so here we go I'm not
even gonna taste it
um bring in this this random person
right now and we'll see how it goes okay
so like oh by the way this is an
important update you know how he got
like canceled some girls came out
against him and there's a New York Times
article what I didn't know that oh it
was pretty big story some girl accused
him of what was the accusation exactly I
don't want to get it wrong
yeah uh they had a a sexual encounter
that turned uh aggressive
um if you will so he claims he's just
into uh rough stuff okay well she would
be communicative just like Andrew Tate
he's into rough stuff that's so bad so
so anyway he said he's sued them for
defamation it was Insider by the way not
uh New York Times but that is a little
bit less credible uh yeah
but that all that being said he sued
them for defamation and he recently
dropped the lawsuit so I also don't like
when people use the BDSM Community to
justify like just disgusting and shitty
and she was like if you communicate and
it's like full trust like it's fine but
I think a lot of like
I don't know I have a friend that's into
a lot of Kank and she goes to like uh a
bar in LA
and she says she can always tell when
it's just like a weird dude that like
wants to hit women yeah um because it's
a different they just aren't part of the
community I don't know
not interested in their pleasure yes
yeah psychos kind of serial killer [__]
yeah
I
I you don't trust me I went to town
um
so he's got really wrinkly nasty looking
shirts
that's his um I believe that's his
girlfriend right
he presented it as just a random person
it's his girlfriend
October so just take one you believe
that's a random person maybe no you just
found it no of course not
[Laughter]
here we go score it don't burn your
mouth
um looks very firm score it and give an
honest to God I want your true reaction
um don't burn it again we got a problem
there miss we got a problem there I'll
help I didn't want to even get known so
cheesy
you know I want your true so the people
at home know this total random it sucks
yeah this video sucks
the talking to Philippines
or anything why is the sound of them
crunching into it so yeah did he add
crunching sounds yeah definitely added
yes [__] added crown for sure
you can barely hear him and that's right
what an idiot because he's obsessed with
like the crush being crunchy yeah okay
but your score go do one yeah doing that
weird freak the timing was off
there was one too do you think maybe
it's intentional it's like a trying to
be self-aware about it like this random
person was really his girlfriend and
then he's just adding the sounds that
don't even match up but they're not
joking there's no like uh there's no
everyone uses it to a certain extent
it's just kind of like being lazy we're
just watching we just whenever we're
watching videos are a little boring we
like that percentage the kinetic sand or
the Subway Surfer or something yeah that
keeps people's attention that's smart I
love them it's a brilliant idea that is
a good one that one's really nice I
really like this one I like it
satisfying that's amazing yeah dude I
didn't make that do they buy it like
that or make it so nice I think it comes
like that probably about it like that I
should get some for the studio like when
we're bored like you're doing The
Godfather or whatever
yeah wow okay that's fantastic okay back
to Dave
dude that crunch that is his girlfriend
yeah first off chicken
bread
chicken I don't know what that means
teaching you weird though dude what do
you guys like crunchy crust is that
something you're into not like that yeah
not a crap I don't want to eat a [__]
cracker because like it sounds like a
crack sounds like it's burned yes it's
not appealing sounds like he's stomping
leaves
[Laughter]
9.8 9.8 9.8
so I guess 10 maybe it was slightly high
but there you have it so again unbiased
review I'm buying
um nine eight I gave this a nine nine so
the the cumulative score so far three
scores a ten and nine nine yeah so is
this whole thing self-aware I guess it
must be there's no way yeah
but this man
oh he has a whole Channel about this I
don't even know that funny these ones
all have like 200 000 views ain't nobody
watching this dog [__] video Dave
crunching sounds oh actually never mind
there's a half a million
whoa I stand correct yes so he gave it
uh he gave it a 10 out of 10.
it's being sold at Walmart
this man has most uh delicious Gourmet
pizzas are of course you know and and
that's right here's here is um Dave by
the way giving a mom-and-pop institution
a zero out of ten as he gets picked out
way he gets picked out that pizza looks
fine you know what I mean looks a lot
better than whatever the goddamn
burnt bread you were eating on like
bagel chips yeah
[Music]
someone just yelled 9.1
it's ice cold they came in ice cold
slice ice cold
ice fishing with an igloo on this what's
wrong with pulled Pizza he's got his
information to shoot on my patio today
oh cool so I'm gonna need you to make
your way out this way 0.0
good colors kicked out National Pizza
review 0.6
trash
Oh my God what a mistake that guy made
what there's a dude on Tick Tock uh MMA
dude that he lives in Vegas and he does
like reviews of family uh oh yeah
businesses he stood on Mr Beast
chocolate did you see that I was so
nervous when when he was like oh uh Mr B
sent me chocolate I was like oh I hope
for Mr B's sake that he doesn't send the
chocolate because it's not gross it's
not good yeah we've tried it on the show
we do like we love reviewing influencer
products the chocolate to Bar it's two
dollars so it is very cheap but yeah
Keith thought it was mid yeah I knew
right next to him oh my God I felt so
bad for him because I knew he wasn't
gonna lie I was like he's gonna be
honest and it's gonna be all right we
have footage of uh Airsoft fatty
um eating one of the Mr Beast bars and
uh it was so funny because I think uh
Chris thought it was like a like a
sponsored segment and he needed to like
kind of ham it up so like he's sitting
on like the Dax flame
and he's like oh oh this is so good he
goes on for like two minutes
exaggerating how good the Mr Beast bar
is Chris is so sweet he just wants to
make everybody happy and it's uh it's
very nice yeah so we're gonna try it and
I'm gonna give it an honest review I
tried dobrics you know David dobrik oh
yeah yeah
okay I thought it was like mid to good
some of the people here loved it I drove
by that place and it was like a party
going on there yeah it's empty now
really empty why
based on what well Sam went there arlena
went there and it was mid the middle of
the day and there's nobody there oh okay
can you get a whole pizza now because I
know for a while it was like slices only
yeah you can
um somebody said if I read it right and
I think it's a good idea if that's what
they were saying that you should try
that pizza that he just gave it a zero
where was it though I don't know we can
probably figure out I think I believe it
was in Kentucky
oh wow Wasabi can take you oh what's up
pork boy is not in L.A
he lives in New York I believe
he travels around for
picking up girls I guess I don't know
why yeah
most likely yeah I don't know what were
the reason he has to travel
where he came up with this like why why
their style not tastes like drunk Pizza
to me if we're being totally honest like
drunk pizzas yeah that's what he said
like drunk food I guess but that's good
I love drawings but
yeah I want to go high that's why I
couldn't have him here I mean people
love it
uh he's just a grouchy Jewish um
he's not a chef chauvinistic no he's a
boy made of pork uh he no he's not a
chef he didn't work at like a restaurant
no or anything no
no interesting
okay so I'm looking forward to anyway
I've got to set that up I'm looking
forward to giving it an honest I'm gonna
say it give it honest review
[Music]
yes
yes yes yes
yeah he's super rich he has a few places
he goes back and forth he has a place in
Miami and uh a few places I don't see
him as the Hamptons kind of people
interesting
because I watched the New York
Housewives Hamptons is super impressive
to like uh young girls
and all all the rich ladies too I don't
think he's interested in that genre yeah
no I don't so back to Amy's opponent so
how did you guys decide to match him up
with Dad because this is a controverty
my gut reaction first
I believe I text you I said dude why are
you doing this aby's gonna get [__]
killed we called you we called you
because I knew right and that was my
reaction yeah yeah because I knew I was
like if we don't call Ethan and talk to
him beforehand this is not gonna go well
we called you and you were you were
confused you were like why
um but you have the best explanation I
think yeah true I guess I do
um
uh a b to a lot of people for some
reason I don't get it I'm being honest I
actually don't get it but a lot of
people don't view a b as like a very
capable person physically for some
reason I'm not really sure what that's
about mentally as well but people say
that about you but
um what else do they say about AV they
don't think I'm capable of mentally
either so exactly right I don't know
you're very you're the fittest person
here I mean
[Music]
I think though that like ab's a lot more
competent than people understand and his
work ethic is uh everybody thinks this
guy's incompetent dude I don't know it
makes me sad it actually actually like
makes me sad because the amount of work
he was technically more stupid so hard
right now no offense to hundar at all
because Honda put in a lot of work and
and he showed up but like between the
two of them technically a b showed up
better for the fight in my opinion yeah
maybe trained his ass yeah everybody
knew that and
um so Dad is a very excited individual
that wants to uh move forward constantly
and I think if you put someone in front
of him that isn't afraid of someone
moving forward and has seen that before
and is used to sparring guys that are no
offense to to Dad but much better than
Dad at Wild Card like
that's gonna be a very interesting fight
of will ab1 get his stamina up running
um and how will he respond to Dad
pushing forward and I think that it is
like in my opinion there's like three
fights that I'm really excited for and
his is one of them oh it's a hype ass
fight I'm really looking forward to
seeing it by the way
just to address this competency the
issue I I think a b is extremely
confident yeah dumb [__] a b and
he's put in so much work
he has yeah I I bet almost everybody
thank you thank you guys for the kind
words slay B they're calling you it
takes a ridiculous amount of resilience
to show up in a gym and have somebody
tell you to go home and have people beat
the [__] out of you with very limited
communication like out of all the
coaches that we have like I love Wale
but like Wally's not about talking
Wally's about like you either show up
and you do it or you like go home pretty
boy the killer yeah yeah not pretty well
I'm a lucky boy but for a b to show up
ignore that and get the [__] kicked out
of him and keep coming back like I don't
know how many people who who would who
would do that yeah for sure yeah so
you're saying even though he's
incompetent he's tenacious
he's persistent I would say Dad is
tenacious in the ring but a B's
tenacious in life gum mother it's very
sweet thank you guys
yeah no the first nice thing Wally ever
said to me he's like he's like you can't
fight you're not athletic you don't know
how to work your body but you know what
you show up and that was the first thing
the first nice thing you ever said to me
after a month and uh that's the
important girl showing up
kind of the most important thing for
sure I don't think like being able to
fight seems important too though I'm
just saying that I don't know I don't
know I like I love Ian he's got a lot of
amazing qualities but if he had a coach
that told him to not [__] come back
Ian would would not come back you'd
think he wouldn't come back yeah yeah I
need to be coached definitely your
coaches methods I've seen it firsthand a
little bit different than AV yes
complete opposite interesting very
different you thrive on that though
don't you baby I do yeah I need it
because you know I'm always anxious and
I'm thinking that if someone was nice to
me all the time I wouldn't be able to
believe what they're telling me but
because Wally's so straight up yeah I
know it's I know it's legit it's the
real deal when he says you're doing good
yeah I think it's a bit of Arab dad
syndrome oh yeah totally yeah yeah Dad
syndrome yeah my dad was that way too
it's like you come home you got an 85 on
the test and your dad's like why not
better oh yeah literally like okay yeah
I I feel bad because Wally even
sometimes will realize like the other
coaches will tell him taking easy on me
and he'll be like no no he needs it
he'll be like all right he'll be like
you gotta understand this is tough love
I'm not it's okay go for it I'm used to
it so I like it really really respect
the way he treats you yeah he's like
dude do not come back you're gonna get
hurt this is not for you right no he
told me that it's kind of a Vibe it was
the first few months he kept telling me
not to do the fight yeah I agree like it
makes you trust him you know it's real
he's how's your training going this time
around it's going good like honestly and
I'm I'm not afraid to say the only thing
I'm concerned with is stamina again in
terms of boxing I'm not worried at all
about him like he doesn't intimidate me
at all and it's driving him a little
insane I think because that's his whole
tactic so yeah
um how are you feeling you think you
could beat that
if I get my stamina to where it needs to
be absolutely is that what you're
training right now the hardest is your
stamina I well I'm training very
differently than I did the first time
but stamina is a major Focus but
um again you never know though one wrong
hit and it's over so yeah that's true
dead is that a Powerhouse though or are
you just kind of a
just a lot of energy going on I mean you
saw the Matt Watson fight what did it
look like to you
you couldn't really understand what was
happening I feel like yeah I think
that's definitely the writing nothing
really right not that much power you
just I mean of course you're gonna get
if you don't and it was so fast that I
don't know what's his terminal either
yeah that's true I think a lot of people
don't understand like the difference
between dancing and fighting like
especially when you're in an arena with
like 20 000 people the there's something
very real called like an adrenaline dump
and it doesn't really matter like how
good your stamina is like your your
heart's gonna be going and it's hard to
like keep that up no matter how like
athletic you may be so like if you
extend it past the first round like to
be honest like we don't even know what
Dad would look like at that level of
energy uh you know past the first round
yeah I mean it just looked like an
insane person beating up a child
yeah true enough to disturb Joe Rogan's
I will say I have a lot of faith and um
Ian and nisa's judgment on this as well
last time the whole internet said I was
going to die but uh they believed that
me and Honda were a good match and we
were I mean we
you know we kind of done everything the
same
um yeah it was a good match in fact
they called it earlier that was some
[__] bro so pissed I don't know he
was on a gas tank in the back I feel
like if he was in a they knew something
that he didn't at the time the rest I
think to us it looked like he could have
kept going but I agree with that well I
I was planning on keep you know I was
planning on it because I've done that a
million times in sparring where I've
kind of pushed the guy against the ropes
let him unload on me and then I planned
on the last he was rope-a-dope 15
seconds but but Wally says it's good
that they cut it yeah Wally said that I
could have got her but he also said that
uh he thinks if I would have went the
distance the full round either I would
have won or would have been a draw I
agree with that I think something that
like we really want to talk about more
this year is like we have the Florida
boxing commission involved which is like
not something that any other boxing uh
influencer boxing event has other than
Jake Paul
um and I think there was one Misfits
card in Texas that used the Texas boxing
commission but most of them don't use uh
refs through the boxing commission and
those refs are like
hardcore like they're trained to see
things that normal people don't see in
order to prevent like serious injury so
like for example if you get hit
and you aren't looking at the guy that
you're fighting and for a second you
Veer off refs will go like you probably
have brain damage and they'll call it so
sometimes you'll see like things that
look really early but like Wale said
about a b the the ref saw something that
normal people wouldn't
um and that's the difference between
like legitimate boxing events and
illegitimate so during that event you
guys had those yeah okay yeah and I will
say like not a lot of people know this
but uh enanis are really involved in
checking out all the fighters and Misa
is sort of like the mother to all of us
Fighters um and that's something that
made this event so good and why it
stands out from the other events is
because it's not just some quick like
cash grab [__] fake beef thing like
that's really sincere all the fighters
are all nice to each other and we're all
being uh looked out for so yeah except
this thank you baby ate this guy we're I
mean we're looking out for him as well
right yeah yeah like don't get in the
ring I mean he's being coached by one of
the most respected a very respected
coach he's called like they call him the
Hawaiian Punch glorier Yeah yeah could
he beat Wally though probably not I mean
that's a good question yeah maybe five
yeah we might have Kawali one of these
years it's fine Wally came in yesterday
we had that open training session and he
was super late he came in for like 15
minutes kept his sunglasses on and
dipped but while he was there everyone
was taking pictures with him he told me
I ain't showing them [__] we're not
doing [__]
keeping it close to the shed I love how
serious he thinks yeah it's awesome well
it's very serious I mean it's like
you know there's a lot of people at the
open workout who have the same mentality
they're like I'm not showing [__] like
you'll be jovial and pretend like you're
doing you know legit stuff but you know
you're not really
you're you're not wanting to demonstrate
your full power yeah why would you yeah
but we had some people sparring and it
was crazy Aaron looks so good this year
really so good he was sparring John
Morrison and he was getting uppercuts in
there and like it just looked crazy wait
do we have any foot we're is there any
footage of you in the
me and Wally we're doing [__] drills
I've never even done before
like I love the idea he's just making up
[__] on the fly yeah is is he coming
this year to the yeah this year yeah I'm
so happy he's coming I think it's
awesome there's like such a bond between
coaches and and uh athletes that I love
seeing it's very sweet and then if you
don't have your coach there for like the
last week I don't know I feel bad for
Fighters that you know I felt bad like
that sucks I wish he could have been
there but
um thankfully like I was already close
with Michael and like yeah I'm so
grateful he was there he's such a great
guy he was so sweet he's a nice guy yeah
is he too nice is that it probably no
he's not too nice the thing is uh we
were talking about it a bit before
um he's nice to me with uh like the
coaching style because I need that okay
interesting uh if like if he was
coaching you know someone who responds
better to like uh negative [__] like I
mean you be doing that he just does
whatever is the best method to get
results I see he's been coaching for
like 14 years or something crazy like
that yeah like a long time
um so and what are we doing about the
mullet are we keeping that is that the
new Duo now uh I mean I like it it's fun
uh one of my sparring partners is a hair
stylist and he uh you know uh he's
keeping it out of my eyes which is good
you have hair on your forehead does that
not bother you no I think it's cool
although lately uh when I pull up the
hair I'm like man that's a lot of area
forehead it doesn't look that bad I mean
when you exaggerate it man yeah okay
it's not I think before your neck was a
bit thinner before you were like working
out so
yeah it accentuated the forehead but now
you look I mean I yeah you like the
mullet I anything he wants uh legit I
don't care people people think like
really yeah ladies like it apparently
they like the mullet yeah my mullet is
back in a big way it kind of looks scary
like in a good way with the boxing and
the mall
yeah all right it's scary thank you
there's a Vibe I I gotta say I don't
know the me people are saying mullet
gang they love the mullet I cannot get
down with the mullet no offense I just
it's it's wild to me that people even
wear that haircut really it's I mean
it's a mullet wait wait what is that
you're just saying the word like just
the word is bad but like the whole
history of the mullet is crazy history
like back in the days just like uh but
there's a lot of trends of like bringing
back bad stuff and it's like I guess
half ironic half yeah I don't know kind
of like pickles like bad jeans or bad
shoes I like it I think people like
Anakin Skywalker yeah yeah
NASCAR I mean yeah maybe it's because I
had it's culture NASCAR Club yeah like
that's that's cool it just
it's like you gotta commit it's like are
you do you want long hair do you want
short hair you gotta commit bro
he showed his uh hairdresser he wanted
to go longer because before he had like
a baby mullet and he was like oh I want
to go longer and uh so the hairdresser's
been letting the back grow out for him
by the way Anakin does not have a mole
he just has beautiful flowing hair oh
yeah it didn't seem to be bull mullet
you're right
yeah but anyway I'm glad you like it I
hate it no I'm kidding I I know it
sounded like that that's not what I
meant well do you have a plan for your
hair no I just sh I just buzz it all
right so you just
doing like unfashionable man things yeah
that's a cop out yeah well I can't do
anything my hair's just curly it just
gets a bit it's big you have a beautiful
hair yeah but he doesn't want to put in
any work that's the reality yeah yeah
I'm like you can do a lot here I was
like laying on the hotel bed and then he
says like are you gonna shower I'm like
nah my hair is like hella greasy to look
and unkempt that's good I was like no
I'm not gonna do that and she's like I
think you probably should oh and so I
did it that's it oh you did it your wife
is like I I rarely I rarely am in like
uh encouraging of like I let him do
whatever he wants but he had boxed the
the day before and it just needed yeah
and she's very encouraging of like
uh like I don't know caring more about
your appearance because for I've done
that for long enough I think not caring
about the appearance so it's it's worth
it to me to like put a little bit more I
see I try yeah he doesn't listen yeah
well he borrows my hair products now I
feel like I'm so [__] like
it's not worth waking up earlier no but
like we'll be going out to a dinner or
something and I'll be like can you just
put on shoes you know and he's like no
pants no and I'm like
you wear your socks and slides
everywhere you almost have to just make
an active like it's just like putting
shoes on it's not it's yeah yeah a
minute I think you just have to view it
as uh expression and that you're allowed
to as a man express yourself in any way
that you want to and have fun with it
um it's okay to not like Cop Out
constantly listen I have no problem with
men being beautiful
I love K-pop those are the most
beautiful men in the world you just
think you're being very efficient by not
worrying about to me it's just not that
important to me yeah you know what I
mean yeah yeah
we do live in a society
[Music]
I made it looking like this isn't that
awesome that is yeah no that's so like
the norm though like what it really is
being like think about like all the men
that are like it is mediocre in style
and kind of like statement that make it
big like I would say mo like David
Portnoy yeah like who's that guy well no
David Portner thinks he's fashionable
let me stop you there but he's not I
mean think of that and like other men
look at him and they're like see that
guy's awesome and he didn't have to do
anything so then they like praised the
men that are like them so they don't
have to listen men who take care of
themselves to look good God bless them
Portnoy is trying Ethan's not that's I
think that's the difference he's trying
to look coronoy puts boat shoes on but I
feel like like for example like Hassan
right like Hassan gets so much [__] for
like expressing himself in like really
interesting ways does he yeah a lot
they're people like like really yeah the
ripers they call it but it's because
they don't want a reality where they
have to like think about not just
getting their mommy to shave their head
every like month you know what I mean
like I do Normcore that's what they call
it I have to do it no it's true that's
valid yeah yeah the vibe is basically
like no one can look at old pictures of
me and make fun of my uh style because
it was just the most average appearance
of the past it is very uh well you so
when I was young low risk low reward
yeah I think when I was younger
I wore really flamboyant clothes because
I thought it was funny and
everyone had a laugh and it got a lot of
attention as I've grown older
I don't like drawing attention to myself
at all so things that are more loud or
flashy I find myself
but sometimes like what you do is pretty
loud like going out to a restaurant like
this is kind of drawing attention to
yourself is it really yeah yeah
you just looked in my drawer yeah
but I I don't know I don't know yeah I
like when Adam Sandler's My Fashion Icon
that's value but that's a I feel like
that's a you don't really mean
Sandler is a fashion icon but like
I feel like you're not doing it are you
doing it like Adam Sandler's doing it or
are you doing it no no yeah is Adam
Sandler doing it like Adam Sandler
yeah he's a king I would say that like
because what he's doing is like
I literally don't give a [__] but
there's still some thought in it yeah
there is some thought in it right like
that outfit right there he's still
playing with a silhouette and it's still
like
I don't know Adam Sandler is it what
about this one a silhouette
that's what I mean though this is what
he's doing he knows what he's doing yeah
like show why Adam Sandler is our Y2K
King he's like like playing with the
shirt and short length right and he
spends time like finding the stuff that
he likes that one's sick
also the woman behind him with the hat
is kind of wait what is this photo is
this real haunted it looks like fake why
is there a like a oh it's a moment
though I don't know it's very
intentional what do you think this man
just wears these pants no every [__]
photo
they're all different they're all
different no they're all different that
one's different for sure Shredder I'm a
fashion Legend you guys need to
recognize
thank you
people are gonna be analyzing photos of
me in 10 15 years talking about Ethan
Klein Normcore God if you are trying
maybe but you're not actually trying
but it's the act of not trying that is
the trying but isn't but there's so many
men out there that are doing that that
it's no one does what I do entertainment
it's not interesting right like
everything does what I do
I'm trying to make a point David Portnoy
no he tried but he but nobody goes
outside with less effort than me nobody
I don't think you're wrong
there's a lot of Reliance on Ela which
is like kind of the I feel like that's
like there is no I try to tell him what
to wear he doesn't listen no but that's
what I mean it's just like the the just
the teddy fresh drip because it's
available at all times in the closet
yeah like yeah I feel like every like 14
year old boy going to to class puts in
less effort than you
yeah I don't you cannot okay whatever
we're going to debate this
um listen
this [__] is floppy as hell it's not
crispy
here's my tuxedo from the steamies damn
just yeah look at that drip okay
I tried to choose this is David
portnoy's One Bite Pizza
[Music]
or one slice it says
that is the most mediocre cafeteria ass
moved up yeah you could ever imagine to
eat Dollar Store Dollar Tree
yeah Mecca Lane is Mecca Lena's Pizza
like identical to that it tastes like
beef jerky is that Canadian I don't know
never heard of it michelinos is that a
Canadian thing
I never heard of it
it's Canadian but it tastes like that
like a dollar like you put it you the
ones that you put in the microwave you
rip the top off and it's got that like
gray film uh-huh you put the pizza on
top there you heat it up for like a
minute that's what this tastes like
oh really you guys don't have any
microwave Pizza
yeah I guess yeah yeah this is a dog
[__]
Dave portno you should be ashamed of
yourself
I would give it a
three it also doesn't look anything like
that pizza that he ate what was that
yeah what the [__] was that
I don't know I'm not hearing the crunch
I just tried to give you a crunch it
didn't work you have a crunch sound
effect back Thursday
I'm not having much uh hope for this
I don't understand why do something so
half app if you're gonna make a product
yeah you're Dave pointer you have all
the resources in the world you're in
Walmart why would you make this [__]
hang in the sauce
it tastes like there's no seasoning at
all makes sugar it tastes like beef
jerky
tastes like beef jerky a little bit it
would be better if it tastes I don't
think it tastes like beef jerky does it
cheese I mean
I won't pay more than like
three dollars for that
deck three for three
yeah what do you rate it out of ten oh
zero yeah like I wouldn't put a number
on that really like it feels not good
yeah Anthony Pantano it's like not even
on this it's the most like whatever yeah
Pizza yeah I can't even call it like oh
that's average it's very much it's not
on something that you wouldn't purchase
that's just embarrassing man I mean Dave
come on dude why are you gonna make such
a [__] product shame on you
I can't tell if it has a weird
aftertaste or it's my lip gloss that I'm
tasting now it does have like a spicy
aftertaste okay I can't tell
all right Dave well there you go one
bite yeah zero point zero point zero as
you once gave that on the pizza place
yeah
what should taste like beef jerky
um I saw a crazy fit of his I'm trying
to find you know who else has a good fit
is uh Jonah gold Goldberg is that his
name Jonah Hill also has something donut
super fashionable yeah Jonah Hill tries
very hard yeah he does yeah but it works
peaches like and Jeff Goldblum true
became like a fashion icon yeah
you might say he's
bloomed whoa
[Music]
thank you
pictures like that
when it's good it's great and when it's
bad
it's still pretty good that's why giving
it 0.0 to me makes no sense because it's
bread and cheese you can't it's at least
gotta be a two right oh yeah it's a two
I guess
too like look at how that is the the
flyest man that has ever lived it also
looks like I'm on the same scale as him
why are you not giving me my dear credit
come on right then wait no are you
looking at this oh that guy yeah yeah
did he bleach his beard
uh I don't think so I think oh not in
this photo but I have seen him bleacher
before and his eyebrows hmm yeah good
for him
it's not my style
someone I started getting like eczema on
my face That's My Style
if you could if you could encapsulate my
style and it's eczema on the face
okay
good for you bro yeah someone said jump
scare pick three words to describe your
fashion and that's like how you can like
work on your fashion so you like
whatever three words work for you
um so like and you just do a little
check before you go out like if you're a
little bit more messy you know trashy
trashy
maybe like what's wrong with you yeah
thank you thank you
what the hell
let's bring what kind of word do you use
like
um I feel like so for Ian for example
like I would say trashy or trailer park
would be one
um like uh untucked or like a bit
unorganized and like
simple
right white well that goes with trailer
trash okay
um but like but like there's three
descriptors that he kind of always likes
to follow he likes like um it's a bit
unkempt looking but it's simple he keeps
it pretty simple he'll have like one
statement piece maybe like that shirt
um and it always has the theme of like
trailer park or kind of just like
yeah that's identify with the trailer
parks in yeah
unpack that
go ahead
trailer parks are cool they're uh that's
affordable housing right that's true you
could just lay them out yeah anywhere
you want yeah they're epic it's not more
space than you need you know it's cozy
are you guys living in a trailer park no
Eva can you can you sum up your style
um it might help to have to think about
that yeah
thinking about it helps a lot
um and it can change uh but you can like
apply that rule to like almost every
like she's done the exercise the person
that I know she's done it with like
people like Jonah Hill and stuff and
like it's it's cool it's very helpful it
helps you like decide when you're like
buying pieces or like putting an outfit
together like okay who am I and why what
you know what do I want to put forward
cool I like it
yeah last year you guys raised 1.3
million
that was nice yeah where did you guys
donate it to uh Alzheimer's was a big
one uh Alzheimer's Association and they
actually called us I tweeted about it
recently they called us to tell us like
where they put the money well
um and it made me pretty uh emotional
especially the
um they put it towards a program to help
train police to better deal with
Alzheimer's patients because that's one
of the hardest things right is like your
loved one is either putting themselves
or other people in danger we're spending
money to train the police not to kill
people Alzheimer's like what a waste of
[__] money
do it like [__] the Police yeah it's
[__] scary that's like no we it's
better spent telling these [__]
hostile freaks not to kill no yeah I
agree research but like if your loved
one has a knife and they're scared and
they don't know what's going on
options yeah I'm not even what it looks
like to see someone with Alzheimer's and
how to de-escalate so that program has
started which is so important because
it's so weird that's one of my biggest
nightmares for sure is like having to
like yeah it happens a lot uh people
with Alzheimer's are I don't know if
there's a statistic out there but uh her
dad had like plenty of encounters with
the police because they'll wander out of
the house yeah he'll you know and it's
really hard in that period where you
haven't been officially diagnosed
because he's going to be going through
his normal routines and then somewhere
along 19 he'll Branch off and go
somewhere maybe he shouldn't well even
when he was diagnosed it's hard right
because you don't want to take their
freedom away right like once you get
diagnosed with Alzheimer's it's not like
all of a sudden like boom you have
Alzheimer's right so my dad up until
like the very end before we had to like
put child locks on the doors like would
walk to the local mosque every Friday it
was so important it was ingrained in his
head like I need to go the mosque so we
would let him go because he would always
go and he would always come back and the
community like really looked out for him
one day he went he just never came back
and we were like okay holy [__] like
this is it you know like and we had to
call the police he was gone for seven
hours I was so uh I was so embarrassed
because I ended up tweeting it out
because I was so scared and
one of the fans uh followers uh on my
Twitter was working at Safeway and my
dad was actually there he was eating the
food out of the Safeway and people were
like that was just weird so security
grabbed him and the the fan messaged me
on Twitter and was like hey I have your
dad when I went to go pick him up with
my mom I kept saying myself like don't
cry don't cry and I get there my dad
looks at me and he goes what's wrong I
just started like bawling I just
couldn't handle it at all it was so hard
and that was kind of like me realizing
like
that's it you know like that's that's
when you have to like put locks on the
doors but in that transitionary period
when you know you might have to use the
cops like it's so terrifying to be like
I don't know what they're gonna do when
they encounter my dad especially because
my dad's not old looking so he's just
you know people would be like oh he's
acting kind of weird for someone who
looks like they're in their early 50s is
that how or is he past or is he no he's
still he's still uh he's very happy I
mean I'm very thankful that my mom like
fully takes care of him and my brother's
super supportive of my older brother I
get a lot of really sweet videos
um he's still he's doing well he's kind
of like
stabilized right because like
sometimes you'll be like pretty stable
and then you'll have like a massive
decline
but he's been pretty stable
um he's still he's still around uh he's
got a funny orangutang stuffed animal he
likes yeah he loves his orangutan
stuffed animal my mom's always sending
pictures he loves cat he's in a good
mood oh he's always in a good man yeah
but not all people with Alzheimer's will
be in a happy State yeah sometimes
they'll be really aggressive because
they're confused or that's just what
they're a little bit more predisposed to
be like right
um and you can't control it there was
like a huge uh Alzheimer's breakthrough
recently did you follow that yeah they
realized like all the research they were
doing for the past 30 years was like
based on something totally wrong we did
talk we actually when that came out we
went to the Alzheimer's Association that
day because I wanted to thank us and we
brought that up and they actually said
that it was way overblown and actually
not really true yeah which made us feel
way better because I was terrified
because my uh my dad was part of the
trials that
um because it uh we we started doing
injections to work on Breaking the
plaques down that they believe are you
know causing all that experimental
treatment it's it's yeah it was in human
testing it was in the last round of
human testing okay um and it was working
really well on my dad really yeah it was
all that he's he was getting better yes
and what happened was I went to go see
uh Ian and stay with him for five or six
months and I got a phone call uh or I
called my I called my house and my dad
answered my phone and he was completely
different he had like totally declined
and I guess what happened was
um so you either get when
sucks my dad wanted to do this right it
was like his choice fully but you either
get the proper doses you get double
dosage or you get no dosage at all
that's how these things work right my
dad ended up having a brain bleed from
the injections
um so they had to take him off so he was
doing really great and then his brain
started to bleed and they said no we
can't do this anymore
and maybe like four months after that he
just totally
when you say he was doing better what do
you what what how did that show itself
he was I mean he even was driving like
he was he was like really like it had
staved it off right because when you get
early diagnosis for Alzheimer's it's
like when
like there's small things happening
right like like my dad was still
coaching and driving and sometimes he
would almost be like he was transported
into another
um situation and he would say something
that was totally out of pocket and you'd
be like what like where'd that come from
so when he was diagnosed like
um he was in that state and then he
started to kind of Decline and then he
started up on these injections and it it
plateaued okay and even got a little bit
better like and your dad was aware of
that yeah yeah he was this was when he
was like that's the sh I think the
shittiest thing about Alzheimer's
um like diagnosis for a lot of people is
like you get diagnosed when like you
know you're being that like you're still
like very with it yeah when you get
diagnosed so he was with it I mean he
used he flew to his injections on his
own he would get his uh John Grisham
books really like those like lawyer
books and he would read on the plane to
go uh to Kelowna to get these injections
and that was like a year before
um he started to really decline so in
that year he was like on it for about
five months six months and then they
were like we got to pull you off and
then that four months it was like just a
total nosedive that sucks it was really
hard but I it made me feel better
knowing that the uh trials are not
totally void that that is kind of it was
like misinterpreting the
story and the data
to make it a bit more sensationalized
and uh these injections that are you
know helping work through plaques are
helping people and they're they're
pretty happy with the results our half
of our donation went to New trials that
are going on and helping people
um which is huge yeah that's one of the
most [__] up scary yeah it's horrible
it's like it's so scary you mourn it
right you're like okay I've I've lost my
dad and then something new happens and
then you gotta like mourn it go through
it again it's equally scary to be on
like either side of the equation totally
yeah no it's so yeah both is just I
don't know so rough
is that available speaking of
Alzheimer's
speaking of Alzheimer's listeners yeah I
literally just typed that too
let's get that are you piping them in
like yeah he's here hold on let me get
him in here it took him a while to do
the tech support because he's [__]
old he's got that AOL I don't understand
computers or technology that sucks
that's horrible
it up
I feel bad sorry I didn't mean to bring
down the
yeah you're killing The Vibes a fun
podcast only I think it's important
because I've gone through the same
situation I'm sure a lot of people are
out there and it's nice to feel that
you're not alone that you've been
through it so
thank you Abe mm-hmm
um Dad you gotta fix your [__] dude I'm
giving you a chance to come on the show
you're okay I mean come on dude don't
you have assisted living or something
someone younger can help you with this
I mean we don't have time for all this
[Music]
is yes got it uh I'm not sure if I
should be wearing headphones or not
headphones are good dad you are nothing
man I'm gonna just be honest with you
level with you now that you are fighting
my boy a b you are an enemy of the show
I'll say I'm an enemy of Ethan and a fan
of the show
well thanks man I appreciate it don't I
don't don't watch bro
I don't want you watching this [__] turn
it off I watch for everybody else I
watch for a b Sam Cam my favorite cam is
never to be forgotten
thank you
where are you where's the video there's
no video can you see me no
I have oh do I have to turn it on Jesus
Christ ridiculous oh there's the
mustache isn't that ridiculous what the
[__] how do you even grow on my stuff
that's right that's real
I thought it was already on those are
the dorkiest guys I've ever seen
these are from CVS from 2004 I think
real secure on there though yeah
those aren't going anywhere huh
what's not going anywhere those head
buds earbuds oh no I can't wear ear the
ear thing so they hurt my ears and they
don't stay in
show a b what are you how you feeling
this guy his ears get hurt by earbuds
you seem soft
uh
I'm okay I'm doing all right that's it
yeah Dad you feeling pretty confident
you've been heckling a b a lot I'm
feeling incredibly confident like
incredibly is equally as confident as I
was against Matt yeah but you know
that's not true yeah that's such a
mistake no come on Everything is
Everything is different this year like
everything last year I wanted to be a
boxer this year I feel I'm a boxer yeah
I'm I'm uh
I'm super scared
I know I know Amy's not scared I'll say
how this is how I feel I don't want HPV
to be scared I want him to be as charged
up as me and I want both of us to
brutally thrash each other because I
think we can put on the best fight of
the night that's what I'm hoping for
brutally thrash baby how does that sound
to you
I just told him out at this point but I
I I'm hoping it's going to be a good
fight I think I'll be honest you seem to
be putting more respect on a b because
last year they were like bringing out
the body bag you know what I mean you
were really laying it on against Matt
but a b seems to have more respect yeah
because I'm a fan of baby I like it we
had like to consider him a friend and
when you're not a fan of Matt whoa well
Matt Matt is uh an immature jackass who
put out a cliche boring rap diss track
and I didn't respect that I didn't
respect him as an artist after doing
that I respect AV as one of the greatest
streamers in the world uh one of the
best producers of the best podcast in
the world so it was a different like you
have respect no I mean I I do consider
dad a friend he's a great guy okay
you are been talking a lot of [__] on
Twitter now face to face you really you
know don't know that being said I will
be a machine I will be a monster and I
will Trash Talk anyone because I can
separate and I will be talking trash
because I know I will destroy ABS that's
not that's not gone that still exists
what I will do and I have a beef with
you Ethan because you committed a
cardinal sin by wasting that much duct
tape a real father would never throw
away that much duct tape involved with
that chair so I have a diss track coming
out not your dad bro I'll just make that
clear
I
want that heat I want the sauna I want
The Inferno I want the Sun a piece of
the sun just blew off yesterday and it's
coming right for your house
I don't know if you've heard about that
have you heard about this the sun thing
that's going on did you threaten to blow
up my house
there's other people that live there
other than Ethan
let's go take out the whole block
you've been training hard I know Amy's
in the gym he's training hard AB says
it's a matter of stamina he's not
intimidated by your physical prowess and
that's understandable I wouldn't expect
him to be because I'm smaller than
hondar and he knocked hundar down I'm
aware of the situation but hondar did
not do at all what I would have done
Honduras game plan was weak in my
opinion it was too polite it was it was
not boxing you think you think hundar's
stalking a b down slowly yeah
I consider him strolling through the
mall and maybe happened to be near him
oh I gotta say I was watching hondar
yesterday I was watching him Spar and I
gotta say like I I'm admire how he
controls a ring it is very impressive it
is very impressive hondar has a very
high ring IQ he understands how to make
someone walk he he leads the dance 20
fights yeah
controls the ring I destroy the ring I
will fight the ring after I fight a B I
will fight everyone in the audience I
will not stop I can't stop punching when
I get carried away
he was punching s fan in the in the
penis yesterday I saw that he didn't
really see him phased by it he's got
he's got strong penis s man well he was
able to take a lot of hits from you and
where's that clip that's why they won't
let him in that's what everyone keeps
asking why aren't you fighting yes man
but they won't let Hey crater guys can't
let him in because he would kill
everybody he's invincible
okay so despite this when is the fight
come on over here uh April 15th
you guys didn't wait that long I thought
you'd wait like a year but it turns out
it was half a year no lesson no no it's
one month earlier yeah yeah
time's just going very fast [__] yeah
does everyone have their outfits ready I
mean yeah pretty much everyone is
planned their walkouts and their outfits
yeah it is way cooler it's going to be
crazy we had our broadcasting team at
the open workout to talk to everybody
and ask them like what their dreams are
for their walkout and
um we have a costume guy and uh he's a
costume guy that designs for uh Canelo
and Logan Paul and he's done a lot so
it's gonna be super legit we're making a
nice one for ab right we're already
working on that oh yeah yeah it's gonna
be sick dude
so here is um
I don't know tell me if you find this
intimidating at all Maybe
I'm not sure the quantum blast yes
[Music]
you're not punching as hard as you can
not there I didn't want to show anything
yesterday I was just goofing around okay
yeah it looks like you're not really
throwing punches my coach said don't my
coach just said mess around don't do
anything
I felt bad because I think that's the
way a lot of people did it seemed like
not not the camera people didn't get
much legit training on camera
interesting I love how how go ahead baby
perhaps were you in the chat when I was
talking about my coach saying that
is staying outside they're like
they're like us around
Anissa and idubbbz know about this my
coach didn't even want any of me to tell
anyone when I had switched to Southpaw
during my training because loser alert
loser alert we were so many
so he went and sparred Ian uh but he
faked Orthodox like he fought the wrong
you know how like he used his right hand
yeah well doopy like a princess bride
yeah and uh so when he sparred Ian we
were like oh he's not that like good no
offense dad but when you were doing
awkward it was awkward yeah at all
because I had been a month now training
at Southpaw and it just felt I kept I
switched sometimes I was like oh no
notice me I was like I was just so the
whole thing was so new to me my coach
was like he's like trust me don't
believe anything Matt says don't tell
anyone what you're doing he's like you
don't have to do that you don't have a
reason well you should tell the promoter
and the matchmaking I know oh yeah I
know but I didn't I didn't know wait why
did it bother you like he didn't tell
you because they're trying to gauge I'm
trying to get capability
that at the time I didn't know I knew
that I just was listening to it so it
was kind of [__] up it was a mega I
guess In fairness to Nathan and you know
other people who maybe choose to not
withhold some information other boxing
promotions like it it would be in your
favor to maybe withhold information
because they aren't necessarily looking
out for you or trying to find like an
even match-up they're just like we don't
give a [__] so long as there's gonna be
some Knockouts
but we weren't looking for that yeah I
really cared about Not Giving somebody a
bad experience well to be Fair who Could
Matt have really fought that was not
going to be a disaster oh there were
people for sure I mean it would have
been better yeah like it would have been
healthier for Matt's brain but it
wouldn't have been as entertaining so
Dad
um
what are you doing about the pituit
Matt's pituitary
funeral service for it and I paid my
respects hey what did you think about
that Joe Rogan clip I never asked you
about that that was crazy you know I
it's interesting a lot of premonitions
that seem that come true I think I am a
little bit psychic and I had a couple
months before I was like I bet you Joe
Rogan's gonna talk about this because
and I'll tell everyone what he saw 100
was an Instagram post because I've been
getting tagged in them since Creator
clash and they have five million 10
million so many millions of views on
Instagram they all say
dad beats up son they read highlight
information and I know he looks at
boxing and finds out on Instagram I'm
sure he just saw that and now everyone
sends me DM's like why would you pick up
your son this is before the joke people
really thought he was my son and I'm
like I hate these games I hate these
people they're so stupid and then he
says and I was like I bet you don't
organize this two months later Matt
calls me he's like dude Joe Rogan just
talked about our fight so I was like I
knew it I knew it was gonna happen but
uh at the same time that it really did
happen and it was hilarious and a great
for greater class I'm glad that it got
that much more promotion out there you
know how did you feel about uh Joe Rogan
accusing you of being on T oh yeah that
that I think is just he's just ignorant
because he thinks anyone who's in mild
shape over 36 must be on something which
says a lot about himself yeah
because he probably takes testosterone
oh for sure and I'm not even like that
like a [__] barrel of oil or
something there's a lot of visceral fat
in there he is he's shaped like a barrel
yeah you guys were saying earlier the
testosterone I I might have a lot I I do
have high testosterone and that is like
a balding thing that you go bald from
high testosterone and uh I've always
just had crazy I don't drink caffeine I
never have I don't drink soda really
because I just have too much energy
that's why I think I do all these dances
and stuff so I think that it helps me my
training for sure interesting
um
high testosterone are your does that
affect the size of your balls or
anything uh so I'll tell you something
maybe too much information I said in the
chat earlier uh my friends always call
me dog balls because apparently they
hang really low compared to other people
but I don't think they're small balls
are tight tight to the dog no no like oh
before they get like them cut you know
they're like dangling low I don't know
my friends always ask me how many times
your friends see peep your balls brother
from my friends forever I'll get naked
for anybody I don't care I did not come
on my dog
let's see uh I have no shame in anything
and the humans are humans everyone
should be naked so they're droopy the
balls are droopy yeah I got dog uh
droopy balls apparently long balls
I think they're regular okay regular
size now A B you have no hair on your
chest none you are hairless beautiful
twink status I have a little bit of hair
coming in now just a little a little bit
of hair coming in now you're 30. I know
it happens I've started to grow more
hair like my face and it's because of
the working out a little bit more tea
it's because muscle encourages
testosterone fat encourages estrogen So
when you say anything else fat people
are beta so fat man bad so what does it
what happens in in a women's body if you
exercise so women will lose their
periods if they go too low in body fat
percentage because of that but does it
have to do with hormone or just that
like you're unhealthy it's but I mean if
you're unhealthy then your hormones are
out of whack but the reason why your
hormones are out of whack as a woman if
you're too low body fat is typically
because you have nowhere to store the
estrogen I saw a doctor talking he says
if you can see a six-pack on a woman
she's very unhealthy really that's what
the doctor said and I was on Tick Tock
so who [__] knows yeah I will say
that actually you had this doctor on
your podcast he's awesome I love him I I
can't remember his name it's time for
school yes I love him he responded to
that Tick Tock and I I do agree with
what he said
um it is true so
it's it's a lot of things right
depending on as a woman where you hold
your body fat you could be 20 body fat
but have abs if you just don't hold fat
in your stomach so it's very dependent
on the woman if you're low fat
everywhere to the point where you can
see muscle everywhere it can be pretty
unhealthy but yeah women have abs
naturally if they my trainer should
like her body naturally she has yeah abs
and she's still like full in all the
right places you know yeah yeah so she
has abs but she's very healthy yeah but
she doesn't have like yeah she doesn't
have like crazy yeah if she does if it
does oh yeah right as a like for example
women who do like the bodybuilding shows
and they look really like sinewy for
that week you can only keep that for a
week and even in that time I've seen a
lot of women talk about how horrible
that was for their like health and
well-being
um this is you might have low sperm
count dad as a result
I don't know
yeah also it says you might have a a
large prostate you know prostate cancer
my dad had it and that's a concern are
you getting tested
I haven't done the levels test or
whatever
um is the prostate when they stick your
finger in the butt or is that the um
colon my grandfather had colon cancer my
dad had prostate cancer my dad got it oh
my God it is okay but uh I don't know I
had my friend I had that finger test a
year ago for the first time and that was
horrible but I have to get the levels
tested apparently I've done the finger
thing because the doctor when I was a
young man thought I had a um
hey what do you call a hernia I was like
I don't know how do you apparently they
can figure it out up there yep and uh
yeah it wasn't that bad I'll be honest
did you have one yeah no no okay but
that's mine well that's different than
sticking a finger in the pooper no he
stuck his finger up my pooper oh I don't
think they needed to do that yeah that's
the Quick Test I think you got two I
might have been sexually assaulted
oh no really yeah I think they just kind
of one stick the finger up like kind of
through the sack area huh yeah no he he
definitely did you know how to feel your
internals a little bit when you're when
you go up here well whatever he
definitely uh wrong I could be wrong
it's a thing it is a thing yeah yeah
okay yeah he seemed professional yeah he
wasn't it didn't seem like he was
getting off on it he didn't lick his
finger no he didn't smell his finger he
probably told you to cough
uh potentially yeah I don't really
remember
but um I I had a strange urge to like
urinate I like felt like I was gonna I
thought I was gonna go to the bathroom
on the floor sounds like he was tickling
your prostate yeah it was very
uncomfortable I didn't like it yeah so
but what I did was and tell me if it was
the same for you I laid on the table
like in uh
how do you know fetal position oh yeah
mine the lady had me like go up against
the bed like that hospital bed and I had
to like put my forearms on it and squat
oh damn yeah that really sounds worse
really it was real fun so you know like
all right get in the position yeah
I hated it but he yeah like at least you
could lay down I was laying down I was
looking away and then he's like all
right here we go
and then he was out I feel like fetal
and it's really not that bad is it like
yeah we have to go to the guy you know
so many times and get things up in there
yeah I know on a weekly basis if you're
getting pregnant so yeah [__] that
terrifying yeah ladies they they are
they're the champions of this planet
keep an eye on that prostate of yours
but yeah everybody should right it's the
one one of those things that colon
cancer yeah oh yeah yeah in 20 to 30
year olds called the answer is really
going up oh really 20 to 30 years
this next couple weeks um
I think it's just an exam yeah you can
like tell from the outside you can [__]
in a box now and smell it isn't that
crazy they're just [__] you could
always do that
well it's legal now apparently okay in
that box and you mail it to them Oh I
thought you said smell it yeah [__] in a
box and smell it yeah I thought like the
aroma yeah
I bet I think dogs can do that but I'm
not yeah for sure right
um It also says uh correct me if I'm
wrong here Anisha why do you know
everything sorry oh I don't know I like
I mean I I'm I just like that stuff
[Music]
I I was oddly obsessed with the
endocrine system when I was in high
school and then I went to I went to
University and I had a weird kind of
path where I was uh education I was in
the education program in Canada so you
pick up major in a minor so I picked art
history as my major and then I picked
Kinesiology as my minor so I just had
like this really weird situation where I
had like art history classes and
painting and then I also had like you
know nutrition and endocrine and like
lifting weights and how the Body Works
she's very into the nutrition health and
fitness stuff so when I come across some
weird Tick Tock I'm just like what does
this mean they're like oh that's
[__] like don't listen Ethan is the
[__] yeah I have a good [__]
[__] radar yeah I think it's a
cancer thing I don't know I know you're
not I feel like me and you are very I am
a Cancer we uh you guys were talking
about introverts and extroverts
and you talked about the bathroom thing
and Ian laughed because he was like
that's literally what happens when you
go to the bathroom wait what's the
bathroom thing I was like when you leave
the room it's awkward yeah you you're
not aware same thing for me I'm just
like yeah like when you if Anissa goes
away I'm just like so yeah I'm in cringe
so I don't even really specialize
anymore so well yeah you're just not
thinking about it though yeah right I
guess we all have different
experience and uh some of us are fashion
icons who are very friendly I'm amicable
it's almost just awkward
yeah
you are a fashion I think
I couldn't try the wedding we went to
together the four of us you guys were
trying oh you wasn't afraid when he does
decide to dress up well now it was uh
John uh JonTron yeah we went to
jontron's wedding together yeah yeah
well like well we met together like we
were both there we were at the West wait
this is I almost don't even remember
yeah yeah I like I like Michael he's a
good guy yeah
that's funny whoa I mean it was it was
very
it was a very generic kind of wedding it
was great
where was it
um his parents were there remember we
talked to his people okay I remember
meeting his mom yeah oh Ian put chills
um banana peel song on and was dancing
alone on the floor oh I think they were
and I don't think we saw that it was
very
very I do remember now I
met we always heard about it Mom yeah
the first time reading her yeah like his
dad gave a speech in Farsi and felt
super comfortable I was like oh that's
some Middle Eastern desserts there and I
was like oh I like this John has the
best uh Arab dad impression yes yeah
so okay let's see we so are we doing
we're raising money for the same kind of
causes are we switching it up oh we've
got so many
um uh Jack manifold put forward the
charity that uh technoblade uh was
really passionate about in his last uh
you know few months of life really
pushing for
um uh sarcoma uh that's a big one uh
SPCA hondar wants SPCA in there what is
that what is that animal and a rescue
sauce
[Music]
animal he's like the big people no
thanks yeah I get it yes yeah I get it
yeah I agree
so we got that going on
um oh I was just saying I was gonna go
with that one too but uh because Honda
and I are big vegetarians
we already clapped for Honduras
sorry baby
Gamers because uh yeah I care about them
equally wait hold on how long have you
been a vegetarian
I haven't had meat in over half my life
now 42 it was 20 when I stopped eating
why did you stop eating meat I felt bad
putting something in my body that I
could look at it could look back at me
and I could kind of have a conversation
with it it could acknowledge my voice
and then I could put it through my butt
be like goodbye it just felt rude
only because it's rude
but only kind of rude you said it's kind
of rare I know it sounds crazy so I'm
trying to like joke it up but like
that's why it doesn't make sense weird
yeah so but I also health benefits
that's another reason I think my colon
might be okay is like no meat and like I
eat so many vegetables and fruit that uh
my Colon's probably pretty clean but
yeah uh I just it's for health reasons I
had more energy when I stopped eating
meat too surprisingly yeah speaking of
which one of the uh Joe Rogan he got
really upset about the government put
out this new like yeah you know what's
unhealthy [__] and it got so mad
about the beef but like it's beef
compared to other meats like ground beef
compared to other meats it was unhealthy
that's what that like so it's just so
funny
um and it is true red meat for colon
cancer and a bunch of other heart
disease in men as well pretty sure red
meat is just like don't you're better
off not eating it yeah yeah I mean I
have it's kind of like like sugar yeah
it's less the better you know liver King
is really weird and shitty that man is
on the verge of death having a heart
attack at any second 100 but one thing
that he was kind of correct I mean he
was wrong but
um back in the day like we were hunter
gatherers but way more gatherers so like
if you did get red meat it was super
rare it was like once in a blue moon
crazy so that's not what he says no no I
know that's not what he's but he's like
uh he was following paleo or like a
correct paleo diet oh yeah yeah it would
be like you should have like red meat
very very very rarely like you can have
once a month but like you shouldn't be
having it every day it's a weird thing
to want to put in your body well the the
I think the official guidance now is
like once a week at most and I think
even that is being like it's a bit
excessive how do you milk an oat I've
always wondered dad so Dad what do you
eat when you have to exercise a lot and
like build muscle and stuff I can't well
I can't build too much muscle so it's
been that's the thing my coach is trying
to work on this year I I take vegan
protein
um a lot of all kinds of different
brands I eat lots of peanut butter lots
of beans but I mostly just eat fruits
and vegetables that's why like I'm not
in Honda I talked about this too with me
because he's basically vegan
um like it's hard to put on muscle so
I'm just lifting more weights and eating
more I eat vegan fake meats you know
like uh that's probably good boy based
yeah so what's your favorite dish what
do you get down with I eat like bad
children's food basically I eat like
carrots out of the bag and then like
strawberries like I don't eat I don't
cook meals really uh you just eat loose
carrots yeah
do you eat
okay that makes sense do you like
chestnuts
I don't I don't know you know I don't do
not experienced with too many nuts I
like almonds but almonds are bad for the
environment so I try to use them too
much there's nothing left for you yeah
exactly do you like chestnuts
cheers
I'm so happy you guys found the long
version
I still haven't been able to listen to
it though it's so good
I learned has the same diet as me where
she'll go out to restaurant and just get
mashed potatoes and that's it for like
cold carrots
bro that was crazy I love that clip so
much
of the Harry Potter a character yeah I
don't know what xqc
if you've got a little clip it went
viral he's just going he thought a wand
was a carrot
in Earnest oh that wasn't an edit no no
no
my other favorite one that xqc does is
like the turtle that's eating the
jellyfish and he goes a jellyfish is a
herb
I mean here it is he's playing uh
confirmed transphobic xqc
who's playing
Harry Potter let's give this one a try
oh
[Music]
charity
I don't know how I'm so good at that
he's so good he knows exactly what the
[__] that is
because love love is a fan of xqc and I
asked love I says is he doing stick or
does he think it's a carrot and love do
you think he's being so personally he's
being for real no that's totally a
French Canadian thing I think yeah yeah
I think it's just I have an accent yeah
I think it looks kind of like a carrot
too no it did for sure but it's a want
but it's it's in a Wizard World he's
able to sell it better because he has
this like look of like consternation on
his face and he it's still like a valid
thing to say like that looks like a
carrot yeah but instead of saying that
what's his accent where's he from he's
French Canadian oh
not really bad with accents I thought he
was from somewhere else
so anyway moving on we've got uh you
know Dr Mike got his ass beat I [__]
hate that guy
did you dirty right the last one I I
just that clip is makes me a little bit
upset it's just that was [__] up
I don't like to say too much about it
Ian it's a professional it's boxing
um I feel like okay yeah I respect that
yeah
um but I mean people are allowed to have
their opinions not very sportsmanlike
okay and are you one of those people
I'll say that I'd be held back yeah it's
okay to say you thought it was
unsportsman life yeah yeah it was I'll
say that yeah yeah good
um but yeah he got whooped on by Chris
Avila was that good for you yeah that we
were there we were sitting like uh on
the floor fourth row back or something
Dr Mike got his ass beat by uh Christmas
I don't even know who that is he's a
boxer right he's friends with Nate Diaz
who's known for being just like a dog in
the cage like just have the most brutal
fight I think he's more of an MMA guy
um but yeah you beat his ass
it was crazy to see him like Dr Mike's
got a good chin on him he took a lot of
hits yeah that's true yeah he kept it
was it was really interesting the first
like couple minutes like it looked like
Mike kind of had it and then all of a
sudden Avila just like stuck his head
down and was like throwing punches and
every single time he would just wildly
throw a punch he would just smoke Mike
in the head he never figured it out it
was kind of interesting Dr Mike he still
said hi to us beforehand and after hand
smiling at us didn't break her it's
pretty impressive what do you mean he
didn't break character he didn't break
character he he's like because you know
underneath he's like American Psycho
well I I don't know but I'm just saying
that's killed a prostitute
I mean I don't know what it is but he's
sort of like a politician you know he's
always been super nice when I say that I
remember the fight like at 3am uh we
went to go uh visit one of the other
Fighters it was just me and him alone in
the elevator and he was still like you
would think of cameras on him yeah just
like smiling and super nice yeah yeah he
could have came up to us with like blood
pouring out of his eyes and he'd be like
how you guys doing are you doing the
show yeah no no I'm fine yeah it's yeah
no that was great that was actually a
lot of fun yeah there's a little
Darkness back there you know what I mean
yeah our coach was mad that he said that
Chris didn't hurt him
he felt like he was lying sorry here let
me pull it up I don't know if we're
gonna get claimed but let's just here we
go we haven't seen it oh this is you
versus I this is him verse you oh that
won't get claimed uh we can check why
don't we up once you upload it and see
if it gets claimed we can watch his
fight okay yeah
he saluted us he got in the ring it was
a very weird uh how was the salute open
hand you get the gloves on oh Club no
like he's probably waving but the gloves
no no I don't know he did this oh yeah
but it was it was crazy
we were in the uh Arena right we're in
the front row and there's like in
traditional boxing nobody shows up to a
boxing event until like the main event
so it was like pretty much empty yeah
the lights were on you know how like
with our event like everybody gets to
walk out it gets dark loud the lights
are on all of a sudden we look up and Dr
Mike is in the ring because Ian was like
I wonder when he's gonna fight he was a
hers by the night no one was there
anyway lights wrong it was just in the
ring they didn't even have music for him
what what the hell it looks over at us
and he salutes us he's like hello so
awkward he's probably just happy to see
a familiar face legit yeah yeah I like I
think he was happy that there was a
familiar because the whole experience I
think is like they were very daunting
especially going his tires yeah against
someone like wait what yeah the guy that
he was fighting his tires flashed his
tires through like bottles like I don't
know if it was there's tires slashing
I'm pretty sure but there were some
there was some sort of
it's not that serious is it well when
you're in that world it is yeah which is
why people think our promotion is very
bizarre it's like you can't be in the
same room room as your opponent you're
killing each other it's not like we're
not unhinged well it's a sport you know
yeah I don't understand it's a sport you
can fight someone and have respect for
them like when Ian spars this guy uh MMA
guy they met once the guy beats the [__]
of Ian for three minutes and then hugs
him after like that's like very normal
for the sport you're you're there to
like compete you don't have to like want
to rip someone's head off to be like hey
I think that you're someone that I'd
like to fight and I want to see how it
goes by the way we did ours our annual
steamies worst influencing boxer moment
did go to Dr Mike pretending to touch
gloves and punches
we did watch it we did watch it we
didn't see this yeah
an option
you are Matt burst Dad yeah
all right I think it wasn't like that
the fight was bad it was more like you
know the dad [__]
I do defend myself in general about the
map why does it lie
I just want to say I see every comment
on the internet I read everything I know
I praise Matt for getting in there
thinking he might lose and he still did
it but I also think
it's insulting in a way to me when
everyone's like Matt's a champion that's
a champion Matt didn't do anything he
was lazy I ruined my life and I trained
harder than I possibly thought I could
wait wait everyone's like oh man I'm
gonna have to cut you off
of the attention
reaching Joe Rogan the biggest podcast
in the world
I mean you won the fight
I won the fight all I got was hate all I
got was hate that was unfair you weren't
paired right Bubba I trained and I beat
the guy but I'm the villain but you're
fighting again everybody wants to see
you I know and that's why I'm so happy
about this fight because I can finally
prove okay I actually can fight but I'm
still gonna be the villain
[Music]
bro with peace and love you're a nice
guy and I'm glad that we talking we're
friends with Amy's gonna [__] kill
you dude yeah
I I will say I want to be hurt I truly
love it
my coach Knew Too without even knowing
anything about internet culture is like
all this guy's [__] mad like yeah
I I can't deny there's a lot going on in
my life and I think that is what helps
but my coaches like my coaches tell me
he's like there's a thing some people
have rage some people have like they're
twisting and it's definitely a Fighter's
Edge and he said you have that edge and
I think what I lacked it helps me with
in the end because like I don't have
like that I'm not a professional I don't
have the strength but I have the
insanity to get me through it which is
is definitely yeah a good strength and
you know at first I was a little iffy
about us fighting because we are
friendly but at the same time him and
Matt were friends and uh he showed no
mercy so I know are you guys still
friends I mean yeah yeah Matt and I talk
uh we're we're gonna go to his birthday
party which uh he got sick I guess so he
still texts me he's the one that called
me and told me he facetimed me about The
Joe Rogan thing I was like oh man it's
gone so yeah we still talk and I will
still be friends with AB
um I'm not I don't want to I mean it's
weird because like I want Amy to win in
a way because I like AV but I also want
me to win so I I am conflicted but I'm
gonna shut it off at a certain point and
uh I'm gonna I'm super hyped yeah I like
you to be super cool I like you too but
I want you to lose so [__] bad yeah
we will be friends still I I have a
question if you do lose
what does that mean for you like how
would you feel how do you continue how
would you be okay okay I mean if people
would have me back I still want to box
uh I'm talking to Misfits about going
and doing one of their events after
Critter Clash because I really love
jukeboxing so I want to do as much as I
can uh I will I will bow to a b I'll
give them all the credit like I I am all
about the equalness and the fairness of
the sport of boxing so I'll accept my
defeat but it's not physically possible
so sorry you know what I do think you
have this great fighting Charisma I
think you're gonna have like a nice time
going and doing all the boxing events
because you're fun to watch yeah that's
that's what that's what I like about
career class I'm happy that was able to
be part of this for my first thing I'm
happy honestly I gotta say I was the
lowest point of my life ever and because
of Anissa and Ian like you've really
changed my life and I can't thank you
enough that I'm so happy I got involved
in this so how does that make you feel
uh I think Nathan changed his own life I
think he did a good job I think it was
your I think you guys guys did it I
think that people will find a way to do
what they want to do and need to do and
whatever Avenue that is if we weren't
here you would have found another Avenue
they believe in these glasses have
changed my life I think it could have
maybe manifested it somehow but I'm glad
it was this way because Critter class is
the perfect I think for a person who
doesn't watch Boxing and who likes like
sort of like you know it's more fun it's
like I love WWE and I love wrestling
that's why I'm friends with John and all
these other wrestlers and this is in my
opinion I don't want to Brand it because
you know you guys are controlling the
brand of krakash but in my opinion it's
like it's sort of the fun WWE YouTube
boxer because we do get in character we
have better entrances we have fun
entrances all these other events are
just like real serious the audience is
really quiet I was at the Misfits fight
with Belle and it was silent we're like
no one's making any noise and then
you're at credit Clash I couldn't hear
my coach I couldn't hear anything it was
insane so I'm happy I got to put on this
show and I'm hoping I can take that
career coach energy to another one after
no matter what happens if I win or lose
yeah it's the only event I'm excited to
watch I wouldn't watch shutters but it
is really fun to watch even if you're
not like a sports fan or yeah that makes
sense we're gonna have to watch along
like we did last year
I love that you guys did that it was
super fun we're gonna do it again you
guys should maybe do like uh like a
prediction card oh yeah
leading into it yeah and maybe put some
money on the line yeah let's do that you
guys like that idea I like it yeah yeah
I honestly last year I was like I love
AB but he's gonna get his ass beat you
did better than I thought you would I
really genuinely think you can beat dad
because he's [__] he's just hot air
dude
he doesn't even eat meat
man I'm telling you like last year I was
like unhinged this year I'm focused
are you farting dad I do have gas I eat
a lot of vegetables and beans I'm sorry
dude save it for later can I show you
guys something
it's actually really close to it but I
promise this is safe for YouTube okay
we'll pick up on it
um I'll have to do it oh right yeah yeah
I know what we're gonna see too
I might break my neck doing this
careful can you see this I can't oh God
oh God what are you what is it oh
Creator you got branded nice
waiting to be crossed off oh my God
oh my God if I win will you put will you
tattoo a b is my dad is my daddy
beat me or I write my own name and cross
my name out and put a check mark next to
your name okay
influencer boxing let's [__] do it at
my house if I lose I'll take them back
let's make some Jake Paul bets yeah all
right and Dad just as at the end of this
I just want to ask that you please don't
go on your podcast and say I'm dead
serious I'm breaking character they
bullied me on the podcast please don't
do that can I actually take like 60
seconds to explain that whole thing I
don't know if you followed that yeah you
did I was like dude what the [__] he
said we're doing this chair gag I know
and I I want to say that I thought that
it would because we already knew that a
b and him are gonna fight but people
didn't know but I thought it could be a
funny build up if the show starts hating
that so I was leaning into the hotel
like being mean to you yeah but
obviously I didn't mean it no hold on
obviously I know this and the reason I
play dumb was because the audience
didn't know and I was like they're not
knowing what's going on oh you cannot go
that you cannot go and say he goes I'm
being dead serious I'm breaking
character I'm speaking right now as
Nathan I'm like dude what do you do how
you gonna say that
the Kaufman bits and this did have a
payoff and it wasn't worth it that's why
I bailed on it and I said Hey
what if people started getting mad at me
yeah like I said in the chair they were
super mean to me when I was at the
office and people like yo that's [__]
up
the bit was that I had planned I had
talked to Vsauce and I was going to have
him show off I was acting like I was
upset I was mad why did you do this
you're such a jerk Ethan and then Ethan
uh I wasn't sure which I said so that
Vsauce or someone could get on the show
and you wouldn't know I would be there
with him and he brings this project he's
working on and it's an actual toilet
with a real human crap in it to say
screw you or that was never gonna happen
I had this whole v-sauce with a toilet
with human [__] in it
sauce
no because I know peace has a mutual
friends and he's like in the dad Series
so I was like okay they'll never expect
this I acted upset about the chair then
he gets a toilet with human crap in it
and then I'm like f you you think I
would have been happy about you sending
me bro play with human shitness
by the way I don't know if this makes
sense because we had to cut the lower
part but yeah that makes yeah it's Dr
Mike from Americans I do yeah
correct myself I actually
think event or the worst thing that
happened in influencer boxing was the
headbutt because that's just that was
[__] insane yeah that's like a crime
actually yeah when they continue to have
him on their events I'll show you you
know there was um I think I have it in
here it's really disturbing to be honest
can you send me it was a Misfits fight
no Kingpin no right social cluster fight
one of this [__] lunatics show star
like got angry during the fight and just
went and headbutt the guy like very
violently right it's super strange
because when you get into close
exchanges sometimes you're you know
you're moving right so sometimes your
heads are gonna kind of maybe bump okay
flash is kind of even even Clash though
is kind of like a violent word they'll
bump and this guy decided like oh you
head-butted me I'm gonna talk about you
wow yeah yeah when bumping heads is one
thing yeah look at that isn't that
disgusting yeah this guy's still boxes
oh
yeah that's a crime that's insane no no
yeah that's definitely a crime I hate
that like
if there's the rules
okay yeah I was saying There Are Rules
like everybody should follow the rules I
just hate that it should be a safe space
in that way like you know what the rules
are well because what you sign up for
right is not that so yeah he could sue
and win there was a kid I played hockey
who he got really upset and he took his
blocker as a goalie and hit someone in
the back and uh the kids uh liver uh
blew up like because it was such a hard
hit and the kid ended up suing the
player because even though it's a
contact sport when you do something that
isn't legal and you cause severe damage
it's not you know I'm getting [__]
there's criminal charges that are
involved as well like that's assault
with a weapon if you're hitting with
somebody because those blockers are hard
right that's like hard plastic and um so
people are still letting this guy fight
yeah in fact he even posted on his
YouTube channel kind of braggadocious
about it yeah my first boxing match I
head butted my opponent so gross I hate
that this guy's name is Ryan Taylor yeah
um
yeah and the other promotions want this
guy on there that's crazy so I hope they
get I mean yeah that's a huge liability
for them potentially it's crazy
tons of [__] and the kid that he
fought right it's really sad because you
also have to remember like this kid
trained and you know showed up he flew
in and just to get head-butted in front
of a bunch of people yeah the
opportunity was like completely robbed
of him to compete right what yeah is
that the guy that was just on Misfits
recently yes he had the I scratched last
time right yep
that was that's messed up it shouldn't
let him on there anymore yeah yeah it is
yeah Miss fish boxing don't [__] let
this freak fight dang
and he's like bragging about it so what
the [__]
huht for a while maybe he also jumped
someone in an elevator it was
a jump slim and detached his retina or
something oh yeah I'll get in there I'll
mess this guy up you should probably be
in jail actually you say your message
I'll mess him up my dog balls are coming
for him honestly I would take that in a
street fight like I would back him
against pretty much anyone dad he's
crazy you know what I mean
I'm surprised everyone who's in create a
clash surprises me because you really do
gotta be demented to the box
so what the [__] does this guy do like
who are you bro
water park videos
oh he's doing BMX at an abandoned water
park
oh yeah
extreme sports bro
hey dude if you're watching you probably
are because you don't have much going on
for you you're a giant douchebag
what
are you involved insulting our viewers
like that
I don't think he's a viewer I think he
probably someone probably just told him
we were talking [__] oh he bought [__]
now he's all angry I just want to say it
is insane seeing how these other events
work like I got invited to do a a fight
like a week ahead of time yeah recently
by a massive influencer yeah and it
shows how much care that uh some of
these other events are doing some well
in more detail somebody wanted a B for a
last minute fight a big fight a big card
literally just so that they he could be
a Fall Guy yep because I mean AB is not
ready to fight and the guy was way out
of his weight class it was stupid it was
like a silly they love that [__] they
love it like yeah they don't really care
and I'm gonna ask the fight KSI two
weeks before yeah and then it didn't
happen
he would have killed me what we're gonna
fight KSI what it wasn't an option for
more than 30 minutes but it was an
actual phone call that asked me to do it
did you say yes
I I I I wanted it my coach was like dude
it's a lot of money but you're gonna get
killed so it was it would have been just
a money grab and I talked to Anissa and
idubs but I was like what do you think I
should do and they're like well you
might not box ever again
I mean I I I get the bag I guess that's
a pretty big that's a pretty good stage
to fight on you have to remember though
brain damage is forever yeah also if you
enjoy okay side that good you think oh
man I mean he doesn't want to lose uh
and I think he'll [__] do whatever he
can to win and I'll just I mean if if
he's going in for the money it kind of
already puts him in a position I think
to get his [__] especially on short
notice like cardio's huge and if like he
wasn't training for cardio he goes in
there it's like yeah imagine dad goes in
there kicks his ass though wouldn't that
be the greatest thing ever I I think I
do have the potential my coach is very
pretty realistic with me even he tells
me I'm a slow learner I'm not a natural
boxer but he said he thinks I could take
KSI within a couple years
good though like KSI versus Jake Paul
what do you where do you guys feel I
mean Jake Paul right now is so much
better
way better than anyone gives him credit
not really internet uh world in the
Internet space yeah
um I actually yeah I enjoy watching them
fight to be honest yeah it's
yeah I don't know it's it's very hard to
do all the influencer stuff while
training to fight and it seems like Jake
Paul has dumped like a lot of that [__]
in favor of just doing this boxing thing
full time right I think anyone who's
trying to do yeah multiple things
they're just gonna get [__] up you
have to pick yeah yeah
so you think Jake Paul is the best
influencer boxer right now you've seen
that guy salt poppy he's pretty good oh
yeah he's really good yeah uh yeah he um
he's also one of these guys though
unfortunately that is like he's kind of
like part of the Misfits crew and he's
very
like the people that he's fought have
not been on his level and it's really
unfortunate because like you'd see much
more competitive and interesting fights
if they just matchmaked better it's like
the guy he fought recently was like way
bigger than him yeah that was the
closest to an even fight but the thing
with
um salt poppy is like his footwork and
understanding of like where to place
himself when like it doesn't matter if
you're big if like you can't hit him
right he's just he's he says that he
didn't fight as a kid I don't think
that's true
super goofy like uh like Montage on Tick
Tock or something where it showed all
these pictures of him when he was a kid
like eating ice cream and playing video
games like see guys I'm just like an
innocent uh like a natural boxer that
you know I just happened to figure this
out in the past couple of years so you
think he has [__] like in the
Philippines absolutely and we've heard
that from people
um but it's it's weird well who cares
though you know what I mean he just
wants to play he wants to fight weaker
opponents you think uh yeah
I mean I think he yeah I do I think he
wants to fight people who are going to
like have bigger platforms and are worse
like everyone wants to fight opponents
that are a bit weaker than them yeah
because it gives you the edge and the
confidence to dominate is that Dr Mike
there no it's Ryan Taylor I'm blind on
my glasses
hello
can I tell the chat that I changed my
name because I love to chat and I love
chatting with them but they don't
recognize me my name is now man
as you all know I'm always in your chat
always watching I'm a big fan I do I do
see you in the chat a lot thank you bro
I appreciate that thank you thank you
so uh
so the event is you can buy tickets it's
happening yes
it's in Florida again yes yeah Tampa at
the Amalie uh it's crazy how well it's
sold already I'm super happy how many
seats you guys sell oh I was so far it's
like 9800 or something like that
yes pretty good or I mean I suppose it's
going to be a lot more yeah they don't
people don't buy stuff early for like
pay-per-view events yeah like day off I
think yeah it doesn't make much sense so
last like year was like 95 of sales were
in the last like 48 hours so the
pay-per-view yeah I mean we're gonna
watch it but I'm I'm not going to pay
for it yet we would have gotten a little
cool exclusive keychain so that's I get
a keychain if I buy it early early and
you would have gotten it cheaper so
you're actually financially very
irresponsible I want to help you guys
out I want to pay you as much money as
possible it's very sweet somebody did
say that in the comments they were like
I actually is there a way I can get the
keychain and like pay full price because
it's for charity and I thought that was
so sweet
all right so here is the Dr Mike fight I
gotta download it
and here we'll maybe send you guys some
crater Clash swag as well so you can be
I bought my shirt already I missed out
last year so I bought mine already it's
day one there's a Dr microphone
man Mike's really staring them down
Mike's actually quite a bit bigger right
oh yeah in every way
he'll bury his head in his chest and
throw that over
head 30 are good
when you're short yeah
look at that that big overhand right
looks sloppy but no no massive power
it's not meant to be because it's like
slowly swing it around it's like so when
you're boxing
comes from an angle that you can't
really see oh there it is again it goes
with a big old swings so Mike seems way
out of his element here to be honest
well percivala has like so much
experience he's been doing MMA for years
like but Jake Paul still crushes these
MMA Legends uh the I mean the the most
recent one was very valid that guy is a
huge but Ben askren actually this kind
of like it's pretty interesting Ben
askren was actually known for having
horrible striking uh so punching on
purpose to bait people in so he could
grapple them because he's a wrestler so
they picked Ben askren because he was
known for having bad punching ability so
it sounds really good right because Ben
askren was like a great MMA fighter but
he was great because his punching would
look so bad somebody would want to come
in and he would you know snake down you
know but yeah Jake Paul's legit you know
you obviously want to set your fighter
up on like a good path and you're gonna
take you know opportunities like to
fight Ben asker and easy you know you
upgrade it to Tyrone Woodley he's good
at striking it's like all right this is
going to be a harder fight but you know
we we feel confident about it maybe he's
older maybe he has a bit more brain
damage and uh you keep upping the levels
I I would say Jake's best most legit
fight was the one he just did against
Anderson Silva and that lasted the whole
distance and that just goes to show you
how much like effort he's putting in
that's very hard to do yeah for sure it
was so good
but Dr Mike's getting his ass
pulverized pretty much which is nice I
like to see that
he's gonna be performing uh
a checkup on himself you know what I
mean taking his own balls but yeah
it has a lot of experience this guy's a
tricky fighter man yeah
he's
he's getting his ass beat or I don't
know if it's just cut that way no no he
is but do you see how every single time
Avila like tries to bury his head in his
chest yeah the whole goal is to get as
close as possible because Mike has reach
and when you get close like that it's
really hard to do anything this guy
knows exactly what to do it's pretty
impressive got his number yeah
Dr Mike probably thought he's going to
crush him
that's a reality fighting a YouTuber
who's never played a sport in his life
and then upgrading to an MMA fighter is
kind of yeah
[Music]
right hands
does he get knocked out no he's got a
good chin he go he goes the distance
yeah
and he earned the respect of Nate Diaz
and the crew for you know soaking those
punches so good for him
good fight though I guess but yeah he
got his ass beat
loser
should be you should malpractice from
being such a dead fighter
professionally he's on one which is
interesting because if I'm able to beat
Wasabi I will professionally be 1-0 so
my record that wasn't a pro fight he
doesn't have Mike
so he's a fat loser and you're
potentially a bad winner yeah April 15th
we'll see would you fight Greg Paul dad
that would be a sick matchup uh
and Ian about this a while ago because
it was maybe a thing possibly and I
really if I don't be a b and I don't get
to call someone after this is my moment
where I want to call him out now before
Evie kills me dude
that would be the best dad good dad
versus bad dad pedal dad versus uh nice
Dad
well he's not a pedo but he definitely
has
it's stupid
that'd be great
so anyway uh Dr Mike rip you know what I
mean
I know what you mean but wishing his
pituitary gland it's so funny because uh
Ian's coach kept saying like that was
our strategy I was like we didn't have a
strategy Ian was so like new and not
sentient in in fighting like during
fighting there was no Strat we didn't
have a stretch yeah right being honest
yeah it's your first it's hard yeah it's
hard yeah
um let's see
well that's about on that to buy tickets
to go out there and support the Creator
Clash websites just creatorclash.com
more Garfield's this year there are
people that dressed up as Garfield and
uh Charlie people cosplayed as Charlie
moist critical that's it that's the
Garfield meme it's a fun character he
just loves Garfield wait what are we
talking about he'll show up in Garfield
yeah there's a lot of fanfare at the
event people had signs they painted
their chests it was like what are we
talking about so at Garfield at Creator
Clash someone showed up in A Garfield
fursuit in the crowd but why I don't
know it's like Garfield have you ever
seen the channel lasagna cat that fatal
Farm did I think that is a big part of
why Garfield is a big meme on the
internet now yeah that's true you're
acting like that's unusual it's like
Shrek if someone came as Shrek you'd be
like oh I get it I don't know that
Garfield had that level of like meme uh
relevance oh yeah it's because
Garfield's like kind of lame and not
really that funny you know
it's kind of cool okay that's a lot
there it is
Garfield I want people to dress up as
dad this year I want to see lots of ties
and a lot of mustaches I want to see
like a moist critical ocean an ocean and
voice critical
yeah
well that's about it for me you guys
have anything else you want to say
anything to Dad on the way out Abe
uh see you see you later dad
this track coming it's gonna be a good
one I'll get my cringe gear
on my dad I'm sure all 50 people that
watch it will enjoy it hey I'm aware my
Channel's dead don't remind me
no you're doing it already you're
talking [__] you're making a difference
[Laughter]
he just literally threatened to bomb my
house bro
um
foreign
[Music]
nice to hear from you can we get the
Tool Time
I can't even hear you guys anymore thank
God thank you Dad as always bye guys
good luck but not really yeah don't need
it kick rocks
bye dad
whenever we finish business calls Ian
always goes bye it doesn't matter who it
is because it's a meme right you got to
be enthusiastic
bye like dealing with boxing guys and
it's like bye like prolonged as well so
you can click the end Zoom call or
whatever that way there's no awkward
kind of like oh I conflicted got it it's
yeah smart so I'm feeling good about
your chances AB I am I'm you've been
training hard you got a great coach it's
going to be a good good fight yeah I'm
excited to uh get it over with and never
do it again you said that last time last
year no but for real though this time
this is it yeah
well he said it last time nobody
believed him really I guess you're right
he's like Bradley he's like uh
Tom Brady you're Tom Brady
sure the greatest athlete of all time
sure
what number fight are they gonna be
um probably either somewhere in the
middle yeah I actually have timed it
like a it's very it's going to be very
dramatic you set it up like a play yeah
I have like a narration I've like
narrated okay yeah the first one was
like a symphony just the way it all
worked out was perfect like it started
with Matt and Dad and then Ryan and uh
Alex beat the living [__] out of each
other all of it you guys were on a good
event yeah thank you thank you yeah it's
nice that was cool last time we were
here you guys you nobody knew what it
was we didn't even know what it looked
like yeah it looked like there were
people who came up to us and said like
fans that we've interacted with after
the fact that we're like if we knew it
was gonna look like that we would have
went but you guys undersold it so hard
that we didn't buy tickets
um and I I think that's just I mean we
didn't know like I I had like nightmares
that we were gonna show up there and
everything was going to be like a mess
so we just didn't promise anything yeah
yeah it's awesome keep it up it's fun
um I'm curious if a b doesn't fight is
there another member of the crew there's
lots of people here to get involved
really Olivia or Sam yeah I was yeah
before yeah who which one do you guys
said that you would fight
Cam said I think he was in love but
didn't Sam say she'd fight Sam said dude
I watched the Elena fight that'd be
crazy yeah
I don't know if I can watch it Lena did
get a little lesson from Wally once
really how'd she do she did great she
was thinking of going in after after
he's done training me but not to fight
or anything I don't know if I could
watch that the reason
she always surprised us like
there's something she always comes like
we did the spicy chip challenge and she
like dominated that yeah I mean even the
clip of the spirit Lena jumping up and
the ring you know seeing her when yeah
knocked down like I think I don't know
like she's also a beauty queen yeah I
know I thought I saw it on Instagram
first I was like what the hell is this
and then I saw the clip out
oh no she here I think she's training I
don't think she's right but but Cam said
he'd fight right Kim
yeah I'm down and then Sam fighting
would be awesome
I'd love to see Sam fight Zach I'm a
lover not a fighter yeah we do have some
uh Good Mythical uh chefs that are
interested in flying staff some staff
not I know who you're talking about yeah
but not him another staff member is
interested in fighting oh yeah no he he
has a like some herniated discs or
something yeah too much lifting too much
lifting
I don't have any herniated discs oh damn
so who's in better shape now yeah
Aiden
oh yeah Aiden Ross
exact same everything is same age same
size same length yeah
but how long have you been retaining
your semen bro come on dude I don't do I
don't do that it's not as like unlikely
as you would expect it seemed like a lot
of people once they find out that we're
not gonna throw like a jack dude in
front of them and say like this is who
your opponent is except for a b yeah
really true
um it you know everyone gets an
opportunity basically to say yes or no
to the fight it's not like we've paired
you up if you say yes to fighting it
means we'll pitch people to you who
would you pair me up against
theoretically probably Philly a d right
but he's taller than me how much taller
he's doughy though he's yeah I don't
think I mean he's lost he's soft a lot
of weight no but he's like permanently
though yeah I mean probably he's just
got that soft doughy um we call that uh
in my family a ham sandwich he is a ham
sandwich definitely I think he has a bad
kidney too so I'd go for that
[__]
but around the same age you guys let's
get let's check the stats on a similar
uh you know Philly age relevancy 37.
same exact age yeah whoa his
what Philly D does not have my relevancy
he's been doing this for longer than you
right but so what he does oh oh oh sup
beautiful look who cares he's got that
monkey that chimp that does its thing at
the beginning which is cool doesn't even
make sense a lot of people know it is
Iconic he is exactly my age beautiful
bastards there's a lot he's known for
yeah he's six foot similar yeah a little
bit taller you couldn't have that
strategy that Chris Chris Avila had of
overhand you know just also no way six
feet he's shorter than you and you're
like six one I think he's lying about
his height he's closer to 5 10. yeah and
then so he had to explain he has a
kidney disease which is not I'm a little
read up about that and think about I'll
study where's the kidney
other crack is my kidney shots yeah dig
into the body were you talking to me oh
oh yeah we were saying would you fight
in the Creator Clash me yeah yeah I
think I would do it nice okay exciting
especially being here to see it all
firsthand it looks so cool dude that
would be why yeah I think you'd be good
at it I just can't I can't watch her
fight I'd have to
turn my head or something that's
understandable I thought I was gonna be
fine and then I just started like crying
so hard with people that you know yeah
it's not exciting you're just scared
yeah yeah I had like three people come
over and come for me I didn't think I
looked that bad but then Ian watched the
footage because like William Osmond was
there sitting beside me filming and I
was so out of it that I didn't even know
he was there so like I just looked like
I was witnessing a murder for 10 minutes
straight it's really hard people are
saying Bobby Lee fight that'd be oh good
that would be a single energy he broke
up with his longtime girlfriend so he's
got like Newfound energy right I would
love to see Ethan versus Bobby let's be
valid you got to be confident in the
person that you're facing would you be
more confident in fighting Bobby Lee I
like Bob I think me and Bobby have a
good energy so yeah okay we're weird
Scrappy doughy oh Bobby Lee's 51 I feel
like yeah he looks so young that's fine
yeah yeah well it's fine so the boxing
commission Florida boxing commission
says that if they pass an EKG an MRI and
their blood comes back they will be
cleared to fight yeah like every disease
known to man though that would be
awesome I'm fighting Bobby Lee
they don't do yeah SD checks well they
actually STD check no no they well they
they do what are you planning for the
ring they check they check for blood uh
born illnesses
who else Bobby Lee Oliver tree's too
young and spry he's weirdly athletic I
don't want any of that sound yeah okay
yeah I I see that I think Bobby would be
your ultimate matchup for me that would
be good yeah
are there any like kind of hudgy like
comedians
that like are in the same stavross
dude oh it's pretty big I think
he's oh he's Beyond pudgy yeah yeah it's
true he's definitely a lover not a
fighter though what about the are you
actually considering this
um I'm enjoying the theoretical all
right brainstorming I think uh something
I say to people all the time is like go
to like I don't know two classes with a
with a coach one on one and see how you
feel about it because some people just
like once you start punching you're like
oh I'm so capable and it's like the idea
of knowing like what your body can do
and maybe like if you give yourself time
like who you can be how how many hours a
day do you train uh maybe or like what
do you think is a good minimum for
someone like me to get prepared
um
honestly I'm not sure everyone learns
differently I'm a slow learner
personally so I think in
roughly six months you can probably
learn all of the basics of how to defend
yourself and not look like a total fool
and how long and how many hours per day
per day I would probably say you could
do that with like
uh
two hours a day for that's a lot of
times no I don't I actually don't I
would say yeah if you started it like
even like a year before you do one to
two sessions for an hour for the first
like couple months and then when you're
comfortable with that you go to three
and it's like hour-long sessions and
then once you get like three what three
a week okay uh and then once you get to
like I don't know maybe like 12 weeks
before that's when you really ramp it up
and you're doing like five times uh a
week I mean I probably would be able to
do a Max an hour yeah I think you'd be
shocked at how fast it goes by
it's not like like I hate running now I
I don't mind it because we do it so much
now but I'm uh I have a very short
attention span and I hate running but
when somebody's just holding pads in
front of you and telling you to punch
things like the hour goes by so fast
I like the idea of fighting like Bobby
like someone I'm actually friends with
and not someone I hate because it's like
win or lose I'm happy yeah you know it's
like I don't I'm not looking for like a
grudge match yeah yeah yeah yeah I think
fighting someone and he wants to fight
me that'd be a crazy [__] matter
Stephen there's a sweet spot uh not
being like you know super friendly where
you're hanging out with them all the
time yeah but you know yeah also not
hating their guts is like right where
you want to be some people are saying
Trisha
I think I'd be I had I'd have that one
maybe but who knows yeah Gabe White Club
Gabe okay I wanted to do a poll do
people think a b or dad is gonna win I
wanted to just pull the audience okay
yeah it is going I'm just curious what
people think maybe yeah I'd like to know
especially that
the h3i sure is like freakishly athletic
nicocado no man I fight Nick there's no
way I don't think there's any world
where he's at right now that he could
like healthily get into boxing Nick
agreed I mean he doesn't even want to
get on yeah does he'll fight me I'm in
yeah you're you're saying that because
you know he won't come in yeah anything
well yeah well it's a low probability
but that'd be [__] sick
it would be sick you work on that if you
can get Nick ocado I'm in all right I'm
voting for you this year AB
s last year I vote I did not vote for
you I'm just being real appreciate it no
I understand I wasn't voting for myself
last year so no that makes me so stupid
well listen to this a b this year
has 67 he's going to win nice so the
audience believes in you this time
around I think you proved yourself that
you got a good foundation last year and
I think everyone's feeling confident in
Amy's ability to fight thank you yeah no
hearing it from Wally really meant the
world saying that uh I did really good
so I believe it I've noticed uh in
casual conversation with Amy that he's
been talking more about beating people's
ass too like if this happened I'd beat
his ass like the janitor there was
something else oh yeah the Benjamin
Franklin guy put his arm around Lena you
said you'd beat his ass I just have
built up rage because in all those
situations I don't do [__] so but you
feel more confident to beat people's ass
now probably huh
uh you know what's weird before I ever
got in the boxing gym I was pretty damn
confident in my fighting ability until I
got there I'm like oh [__] yeah so yeah
it does humble you oh yeah yeah so I
would fight Nick Accardo
I would fight Jimmy Lee
oh bit Jimmy Lee version the outline
he's like 80. oh
yeah yeah no that would be good Jimmy
Beast Jimmy Beast
um
yeah go for the [__]
now Beast is huge he'd beat my ass oh
yeah he's so tall yeah he's super tall
um
okay you're dodging my challenge here
Ethan I'm not gonna fight you Dan you're
too close it's like brothers all right
fine [__]
I think you I think he'd beat my ass
though
physically you're way ahead of me
right now
you know give it a year also you're off
The Vape oh yeah they're huge I got the
one huge lung capacity
I don't know why I feel like Dan could
throw a punch
I did Karate when I was a kid I'm I'm
technically a black I knew that okay I
am a boy you're a black belt I am well
that kind of knowledge stays with you
bro don't laugh it does help yeah yeah
it actually helps like specifically with
footwork like being able to move in and
out properly I never even learned how to
do a punch like period not even like
karate have you ever been in a fight
Ethan like even I have not been in a
fight since uh Walt someone cut in front
of me on wall ball in fifth grade okay
that was the last time I've been in a
fight Dan's actually uh The Karate Kid
his name's Daniel he's from the valley
Danielson that's right dating Ali oh
that's right oh [__] all the lines
yeah I'm not gonna be your Cobra Kai
[__] Johnny a lot of people are
saying Tom Segura but he's really that's
a great ass dude I don't know if any of
you guys see him but although he's like
her now he yeah hear it himself he like
broke his leg and arm
oh my God I don't think it's actually a
great ball I don't know that Tom I mean
he's older than he's a bit older than me
right Tom yeah but he's been hitting the
gym no he looks good he's fit for sure
43. Ryan Kavanaugh
I would fight
wonder if he would ever do that he's a
weird guy I feel like he might each
wanted to come on our show or initially
that's what I'm saying I think he likes
confrontation so he might do it I think
he thought he was so Charming uh he need
to get in front of our audience and win
everybody over yeah
that's so uncomfortable yeah he's yeah
would you box ELO I don't think so so
Ethan's more likely to do it than you
you think I didn't think he is but he
seems to be thinking about it well
there's certain opponents right I think
that would that would excite me enough
to get involved right I really don't
like the idea of punching somebody
really yeah yeah that's fair like on the
actual like the actual action of it I
really don't think I'm gonna like it
yeah
yeah that makes sense I have been
exercising and I'm enjoying it so I kind
of get the excitement about it but I
don't think I want to punch anybody
people are saying Jack Black sure that's
a good match oh he's interested that is
a good matchup he recently uh didn't he
find Dax at a park and tell him he was a
big fan at least that's it seriously
yeah and he was like Jack Black was on a
park bench and he he saw me and yeah I
don't know if Dax was lying about it
that sounds like a lie but like what it
was so Random we were like at a cafe it
was like 11 o'clock on a Tuesday yeah I
doubt that happened Jack's son is a huge
fan of YouTube like right yeah he's
always rocking it's funny like this
comment ELO was in the idea if she can
do it it's like you guys I didn't fight
anybody you know I like I was a
secretary yeah like going to the Army is
like a job it doesn't mean that I was
fighting people Howie Mandel would be a
good fight oh yeah yeah I would like
that so here's my possible opponents
that I would I would agree to
Howie Mandel
Jack Black
Jack Black would be my ass he's weirdly
athletic too Howie Mandel is very fit no
how he's always [__] just he's a
germaphobe he wouldn't get anything
different weight he won't even Shake
anybody's hands he's not he's not yeah
he's right right right
nothing uh Nick ocado dream matchup
potentially Bobby Lee I wonder if Bobby
would agree with that Bobby for sure
wouldn't train at all though so that'd
be good for me he would not prepare at
all
how he's 67. really he looks way younger
he looks way younger yeah he'll look a
lot older after fighting me
people are saying Tim pull the
quartering I don't want to get involved
yeah everyone thinks of yeah people like
that I don't want to clout up like
actual shitty videos yeah exactly we
don't want to talk to them yeah yeah we
would have to communicate with them I
have to care about people you know it's
hard to pretend to care about the
quartering you know right right Stavros
would be awesome he's been working out
too though yeah
oh actually either you've scrapped with
David dobrik before
you beat his ass oh I forgot about that
when I'm happy oh did you forget about
this
I love that
exact hair color it looks just like her
it's so convincing I would think it's me
oh you you're you're a good fighter man
you got that fighting over here
[__] that's so funny
and I would love to see you fight I'm
not gonna lie would you fight uh Theo
Von
Theo Volo he's like athletic
that wouldn't be a fair fight oh okay so
they got to be fan well like
a similar starting point yeah what if
you got a little bit more in shape
beforehand no but he's got like Decades
of being in shape this is a different
thing yeah
yeah I agree I think I from the vibe
that I get from you I do agree we'd have
to pick somebody that's at where you're
at and then whoever wants to like put in
the most effort will win I like that
idea I can ask Bobby he might actually
be down yeah cool
that'd be sick because I know he's not
gonna prepare
what kind of makeup go up you're both
Just Not Gonna Wanna box me how should I
afford this do you want to box me
and a YouTuber
boxing thing for charity
next year
no I'm right no I'm talking about in
March April
we're like mystery fight so do you think
I could probably get a trainer to come
to my house right for sure yeah that's
what I'd have to do yeah
if I had some because right now I'm
already exercising an hour a day yeah
but you're doing it at like 2 A.M yeah
that's not maybe maybe I get a [__] up
trainer on my time there are a little
quirky some of them yeah they just get a
you know a couple of what do you need a
[__] uh speed bag they just come with
bits you don't need anything yeah really
you don't need any equipment probably
towels yeah the trainer like time and
place and I'll just show up and do the
thing with you well I like that uh Ryan
McGee trained in the park a lot it's
like out in the park with his uh trainer
so he's a beast yeah
let's see Bobby might say yes because
like I said he broke up and he's just
like a little [__] up in the head now
so there's something about like he's
always been [__] in the head but yeah
the post breakup like grind I'm sad he
just broke up so maybe he's like oh yeah
he's having a midlife crisis for sure oh
[__] that's so sad
he's 51. but he looks younger
true
you know
yeah we just have to get him an EKG
completely related to Bruce Lee it was
one of the results that's a crazy
question what
um who else could I potentially yeah
me Canyon would bump me on the head like
Andre the Giant he's massive oh really
easy big yeah yeah he's really big
um I'm seeing I'm looking at the
the suggestions
in the chat Ray William Johnson [__]
he seems pretty bad Chris Reagan wanted
to fight Ray William Johnson but we
couldn't get in contact with him wait is
Ray William short yeah oh he's shorter
yeah
what do you think about the Chris Reagan
Froggy Fresh match up froggy seems like
kind of so is Chris oh yeah really I
didn't know that he's yeah he's getting
there he's made a lot of progress he he
posted a picture recently his neck was
looking thick good that's that'll be
interesting but he uh
we went to John Morrison's uh wrestling
show so far last night and uh we were
all there and it was a lot of fun
um and they're very friendly about the
whole situation so it's I don't know
that's going to be a fun fight but
they're both taking it very seriously
yeah very seriously I'm seeing people
sing
um
Matt Haas
he always beats Us in the podcast
category oh and I says who the [__] is
Jay Shetty
weird well how tall is he get let's get
some stats on Jay Shetty get some stats
do you like the idea of like throwback
things like pranksters and [__] like
that it depends who yeah they have to
have like kind of a fun attitude like
they don't take it too seriously yeah
yeah I'd say sofa but I don't think he's
allowed back in the country yeah he has
a warrant for sure for scamming people
yeah a lot of those guys are really
quite psychotic so it's difficult
Patrice Wilson would literally tear me
limp from limb dude
uh Jay Shetty is five eleven and how old
is Jay Shetty 31 so a little younger but
young yeah
not too bad
[Music]
all right well there you go
oh wait did he message me back no
so it's Bobby Lee or Nick dude Nicki
Carta would be a dream fight he'd have
to lose so much weight that'd be very
maybe it's good for him maybe because
he's been saying he wants to lose weight
maybe it's a good opportunity for him it
would be it'd be cool to see Ryan toys
review I would fight yo you can grab
Barry Ethan bradberry's a psycho dude
I'm not buddy yeah psycho energy yeah
Jeff Dunham I would fight
oh man that's a puppet guy huh yeah
would you fight uh copper cap
copper cab gingers have no souls
okay I think I he I think I know wait
what he got all wait he's a marshall
wait what I missed a chapter yeah yeah
he fought Gavin McGinnis or something
didn't he yeah he did he like had some
weird like funny brawl in a gym with
Gavin McGinnis yeah what the [__]
happened to him yeah oh yeah he probably
wouldn't want to fight him he's too big
oh my God oh my God
no
he said some goofy old internet yeah
he's an old internet meme
yeah you just have no souls looks like
Smoke's coming out of his ear
foreign
well there it is
you know what all right it's on the
table it was like two or three people
yeah all right it's on the table fine
charity baby yeah
thank you
thank you guys look forward to you
I love to watch the song fight but yeah
apparently he says he has a bad back so
I get that you want to do any permanent
damage we were hoping that when he went
and did pad work with uh myth and
everybody uh that he would get
interested but it seemed that it no yeah
it didn't look like what about white
claw Gabe
it's a little weird yeah too obscure
it's very Niche which I mean would you
ever think about getting shoe nice
involved [__] now uh he's too unknown
you think you know he just like awful to
work with for sure you experienced that
yeah
it's so interesting he lives on every
video also could he pass an EKG no um
what about shirtless Eddie info bran
foreign
you know she died yeah oh yeah we were
really we're gonna do a documentary on
oh really everything
we were so close to getting her scooter
we were off by like a a week yeah we
just missed it so she just missed it
yeah yeah so he was having an estate
sale and damn I was like guys go get
that [__] scooter and apparently they
had just pawned it off like a week wow I
was gonna like and put it in a
encase it in uh what do you call like
the silicone the big old Brazil yeah
[Laughter]
love and casing things in red dude it's
so cool
doing it for something that [__] big
that was insane that would be so cool so
much Horizons
um you've seen the with the Chick-fil-A
resin yes
it's a special one that's for love it's
waiting for love yeah thank you all
right guys I'll fight Helen Keller she's
still alive
yeah
she's a liar by the way
[Applause]
thank you Anisa thank you Ian idubbb
thank you guys
creator of the creatorplash.com yes our
boy AB is fighting Dad we have a lot of
confidence yeah Shane Dawson he probably
wouldn't fight would he probably not
yeah
why not maybe I think there were so many
people we didn't think would say yes
that said yes Froggy Fresh was one of
them that was the funniest thing like he
he just hadn't been doing things for
like the past five years he's like oh
what a great
like fun thing to do I was like oh how
bizarre that you'd be interested in this
if you get um that's it Shane Dawson I'd
fight Shane Dawson okay okay we'll add
that to the list yeah interesting we'll
pursue that
um and if you can get therapy gecko if
we're both dressed up in there and Gekko
be a hell of a fight Arab world news
herb world news
not familiar with that one's pretty
obscure what about you Anisa I wanted to
I was training but I I have so much
brain damage that I'm not I can't from
wait really lacrosse yeah oh oh yeah I
played uh men's lacrosse uh as like uh
from 14 to 21 or 20. uh I got a lot of
concussions from that I have a 11 minors
and two majors
whoa yeah all right we gotta go thank
you guys we'll see you on Monday
anything coming up next week
um we do though it's not 100 confirmed
so I don't want to announce it so that
we can let people down again it's not
any we'll talk about it after the show
say it yeah
type it to me
[Laughter]
it's being difficult to be difficult no
I Wanna Know
oh yeah dude yeah don't say it
that's a really good guy it's a really
really good call
it's a really good call
I want to be super excited all right
guys have a great weekend Monday
have a good weekend toodles
[Music]